Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum seit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmetische angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove und.
Wir führen hier unsere Gesprächsserie vor Ort mit Unterstützung vom Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin.
Und auch wie immer mit unterstützung.
interessanten leuten die uns kunde geben können über ihre wissenschaftliche und technische arbeit
in diesem bereichen die wir hier behandeln und heute möchte ich gerne auf ein
thema zurückkommen was wir tatsächlich hier schon einmal behandelt haben nämlich in der siebenundfünfzigsten ausgabe von raum zeit und die zahl kündigt es schon an das ist 'ne weile her tatsächlich erschien die sendung am achtzehnten dezember
zweitausenddreizehn also fünfhundert jahre ist es her und das war ein tag.
Vor dem start von gallia und das thema war gaia die raumsonde die angetreten ist unser universum.
Vor allem die milchstraße aber auch darüber hinaus.
Komplett neu zu vermessen und hier daten zu liefern und während wir uns bei der folge vor allem auf die mission konzentriert haben und geschaut haben was denn hier die herausforderungen sind so ein projekt überhaupt erstmal in gang zu bekommen.
Ja hat der staat mittlerweile stattgefunden und das gerät hat gearbeitet und hat auch schon einige ergebnisse produziert und darum soll's also heute gehen den geier stern katalog und äh alles.
Und dazu begrüße ich jetzt zunächst einmal mein gesprächspartner für heute nämlich stefan ja schönen guten tag herzlich willkommen bei raum zeit.
Ja ich freue mich ein bisschen was über diese spannende mission zu erzählen.
Ja da ist auch einiges zu erzählen vielleicht mal zu dir du bist bei der universität heidelberg untergebracht im zentrum für astronomie und dort konkret denke ich am anstrom logischen rechnen institut das klingt toll.
Ja das hast du rechnen institut hatte meine ganz praktische aufgabe für jeden bürger nämlich kalender zu machen
dass es geht zurück auf der siebten auf das geländer partien von siebzehnhundert und ursprünglich war dieses institut in berlin und es gibt immer noch eine person bei uns
robert schmidt der kalender macht aber die restlichen leute im institut die machen inzwischen andere dinge und eine der dinge die im rechten institut bei uns lange zeit gemacht wurden und auch jetzt mit gar ja wieder aktuell gemacht werden das ist die astronomie trixie also die vermessung des stern himmels.
Kalender also was sehen wir jetzt so von kalender kalender normalen kalender.
Ja ja da geht's wirklich darum dass man zum beispiel mond positiv die mondphase natürlich hat die auf dem untergang.
Aber eine ganz wesentliche rolle spielen zum beispiel auch festtage die ja auch oft castro mischen hintergrund haben sowohl im.
Als auch im jüdischen oder im islamischen kalender und äh da
beschäftigt sich derjenige mit und das ist immer noch sozusagen etwa ein kleines büchlein was auch herausgegeben wird wo wo es darum um die sogenannten kalender grundlagen gehen die also verlage die dann
dann die daten aus diesem buch herausnehmen aber das ist wie gesagt nur noch eines von vielen dingen die da gemacht werden aber ursprüngliche ganz praktische aufgabe die hinter dem astronomischen rechnen institut steckt.
Also es war sozusagen auch der grund warum es überhaupt gegründet wurde.
Genau und es war dann später in berlin da im und nach dem zweiten weltkrieg ist es dann nach heidelberg gekommen da sind sie.
Warum.
Ähm es
das hatte glaube ich damit zu tun dass dann weil es im ostteil von berlin war da die leute dann nach westen gegangen sind haben dann auch die entsprechenden teile und geräte und bücher und sowas mitgenommen und es wurde dann in heidelberg.
Gekommen.
Ja also jetzt astro meti sozusagen eine abteilung der gastronomie die sich konkret mit der vermessung der sterne und ihrer position und all dem geschäft.
Genau also das ist also eigentlich etwas womit sich astronom über viele jahrhunderte praktisch ausschließlich beschäftigt haben ist der ging es hauptsächlich darum zum beispiel planeten sich bewegten hatte natürlich auch mit dem
ursprünglich mal mit astrologischen dingen zu tun dazu braucht man auch dann die position der planeten und
ja die vermessung sternhimmel wie gesagt war über jahrhunderte eigentlich das was astronom fast ausschließlich machten auch erst als den teleskope aufkam und wo man dann auch die körper mal direkt
sich angucken konnte insbesondere die planeten dass man da strukturen drauf sehen konnte oder als.
Kopie aufkam als man das licht genauer untersuchung konnte und dann gucken konnte welche eigene physikalischen eigenschaften können wir bei sternen messen oder strukturen der milchstraße zu sehen das ist etwas was eigentlich erst na ja so ein ende des
neunzehnten jahrhundert so richtig los ging das andere die gebiete hinzu kam aber die astronomie trieb bliebt nach wie vor eine der wesentlichen grundlagen und es ist auch heute noch die eine der wesentlichen grundlagen für praktisch alle gebiete astro.
Hatte die uni heidelberg auch 'ne eigene beobachtung station.
Die uni heidelberg hat die sogenannte landes sternwarte die zu auch genau wie das astronomische rechten institut zum zentrum für astronomie der universität heidelberg gehört da gibt's auch noch ein drittes institut das institut für theoretische astrophysik und dort auf
berg auf dem königsstuhl stehen auch noch teleskope die.
Teilweise noch für wissenschaft benutzt werden aber hoffe heute hauptsächlich ist es natürlich auch eine historische sternwarte die aber für ausbildung zwecke zum beispiel noch ganz wesentlich benutzt.
Grüße in der region.
Direkt ähm in der nähe von heidelberg ist der höchste berg.
Und du also wie bist du so in den topf gefallen ist auch schon zu den mondlandung infizierten oder was war so der grund sich diesem thema zuzuwenden.
Ja also die apollo mission haben sicherlich sehr viel zu tun mit der faszination des feld eins für mich also ich meine wir haben jetzt gerade in wenigen tagen in einem monat genau.
Den fünfzigsten jahrestag der mondlandung und ich konnte leider die mondlandung durfte ich nicht sehen ich war in einem kinderheim weil meine mutter irgendwie
cool war und äh durfte es erst am nächsten morgen dann die aufnahmen sehen ich interessiere mich schon dafür aber das kam dann so im laufe der auch der weiteren abholung mission dass ich natürlich darauf bestanden habe alles was da an live-übertragung dann kam direkt zu sehen und äh ich hab
natürlich alles in der stadtbücherei mir angeguckt was es zu dem thema raumfahrt.
Es ging wirklich mit drauf hat bei mir an und die astronomie kam eigentlich dann erst so dazu als ich dann mit äh
ähm einem freund von mir 'n feld sprecher so ein paar erste beobachtung gemacht habe dann hab ich mich auch
astronomie verein angeschlossen wo der natürlich auch 'n bisschen bessere teleskope vorhanden waren und anderen gruppen sodass ich dann auch ein bisschen hinein kam das kieler planetarium spielt eine rolle wo wo ihr auch.
Hatten wo wir uns regelmäßig getroffen haben.
Und so kam es dass eben von der raum vater begeisterung dafür dass man sowas tolles macht wie zum mond zu fliegen interessiert ich mich dann irgendwann auch für das weltall insgesamt für die planeten für die sterne für die milchstraßen und alles was so dahinter steckt.
Beim apollo,
mission also ja produktionen waren ja viele mission und elf war dann eben die erste wo tatsächlich dann mal fuß auf
den mond gesetzt wurde hat ja die nasa grade so 'ne ganz ihre webseite rausgebracht hallo äh in realtime dort ort wo sozusagen
all die ganzen vorgänge
sprüche die gesamte kommunikation der crew der astronauten des bodenpersonal als alles was ein video ein foto material vorhanden ist sozusagen in echtzeit abgespielt wird und äh ich habe mir das mal eine weile angeschaut so und
bisschen schwierig sich sozusagen da rein zu versetzen war ja auch eine andere medien realität denke heute fernsehen na ja läuft so nebenbei damals war das ja so.
Das höchste und dass das irrste was es überhaupt gab an so etwas auch noch in echtzeit teilnehmen zu können das hat glaub ich viele in so 'n
positiven shop zustand versetzt.
Ja also ich hab
das mir jetzt noch nicht angeguckt aber ähm ich kann mir vorstellen dass das eben auch toll sowas nochmal nach zu erleben aber man muss dann auch die technischen einzelheiten solcher funksprüche dann auch genau kennen inzwischen glaube ich wirklich mehr verstehen von dem was sie als ich damals verstanden habe ich war neun jahre als die mondlandung war
und wie gesagt ich kenne eine menge leute die so auch die begeisterung für
astronomie teilweise auch für physik äh durch die mondlandung bekommen habe ich meine man kann über den sinn solche.
Der damaligen mondlandung die ja viel auch mit dem kalten krieg und mit der
mit dem wettbewerb zwischen eben der usa und der sowjetunion zu tun hatte sehen ob das das geld wert war ich würde sagen es war alle mal das geld wert aber insbesondere auch die begeisterung der leute dass man irgendwie ein projekt hat was man wo man weiß das kann man nur mit große anstrengung hinbekommen und.
Das innerhalb von zehn jahren ich glaube heute wird es niemand wagen ich meine gute trump sagt jetzt.
In fünf jahren wieder auf mund sagt das glaube ich noch nicht aber damals war das natürlich sehr mutig von kenne die so eine ankündigung zu machen und dann äh.
Eigentlich auch ein recht friedliches projekt zu haben denn ich meine es gab zwar immer militärs die dann auch davon träumt der atomwaffen stationären in der damaligen zeit aber die saturn fünf mit der
volle astronauten zum mond geflogen sind eigentlich die erste zivile rakete muss man sagen alle anderen raketen waren eigentlich hauptsächlich gebaut um atomraketen in dieser region oder umgekehrt zu.
Äh schießen aber die saturn rakete wurde wirklich entwickelt für diesen einzelnen zweck zum mond zu fliegen und dort äh auch zivile.
Dinge zu machen und den mund zu untersuchung und zu zeigen dass man es kann ich denke dass es auch so etwas was äh 'ne faszination hat dass man etwas macht wie neue welten zu entdecken da nun ist der mond zwar nur unsere aller nächste nachbarschaft aber
es ist alle mal interessant da würde ich sagen als das man die ganze zeit mit einer um die erde kreist ich meine sie tausend mal weiter weg als als das und
solche dinge faszinierend natürlich junge leute so wie ich damals war und daher kam ganz großer teil der begeisterung
dafür und dann interessiert ich mir natürlich auch irgendwann für physik und alles was mit zur naturwissenschaften zu tun hatte und hatte dann auch nicht vor.
Jetzt direkt astronom zu werden sondern dann hab ich gedacht nachdem ich denn die schule hinter mir hatte ich studiere jetzt erstmal physik da kann man sich.
Und hatte eigentlich bis kurzform die blumen auch noch nicht ja die idee dass ich dann unbedingt in die astrophysik haben natürlich hatte ich mir zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt dann schon
fast alle vorlesungen die in astrophysik in kiel damals angeboten wurden ich hab da studiert bin ich gewesen aber äh dann erst als minimalen später die blume doktor vater dann gefragt ob ich bei ihnen.
Astrophysik gelandet hab mich dann lange zeit mit weißen zwerg stern beschäftigt also noch lange nicht mit astro materie astronom betrieb achte ich damals ja es ist sicherheiten.
Gebiet was notwendig ist denn astro methodisch daten muss man wann immer man irgendein himmelskörper untersucht auch benutzen insbesondere die entfernung angabe von stern die da kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf das ist 'ne ganz ganz,
und die auch sehr schwierig zu messen ist aber ich dachte immer im prinzip ist das erste mal na was sehr fundamental ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen langweilig ist und äh
davon bin ich inzwischen vollständig ab weil ich dass die spannung auch von diesem gebiet sehe und vor allen dingen wozu das am ende führt und aber auch die interessante mathematik die dahinter steckt wie man dann am ende so ein stern katalog aus rot daten macht.
Und mit hilfe von solchen satelliten daten das ist wirklich etwas ganz ganz faszinierendes und.
Ja dann bin ich hab ich weiter an weißen zwergen gearbeitet war dann zwischendurch auch in mal kurz in den usa in rutsch da ist mein spätere doktor vater dann auch hingegangen der hat eine stelle gehabt und hab da weitergearbeitet,
in ja genau weil in berlins in jana und hab da auch dann gearbeitet was für ein halbes jahr und dann nochmal der promotion war ich lange
noch in göttingen gewesen und in tübingen in tübingen bin ich übrigens schon angestellt gewesen für ein astronom betrieb projekt das aber nie was geworden ist da
da ging es darum dass ich damals eine stelle suchte und äh der professor werner in
tübingen hat dann gefragt ob ich daran interessiert wäre mich damit zu beschäftigen und dann könnte ich bestimmt auch noch ein bisschen arbeiten an weißen zwergen nebenbei und damit hatte ich eine stelle das ist das die war projekt ein,
auch von heidelberg federführend organisiertes projekt gewesen ein deutscher astro mitreisen liegt der
noch nicht die genauigkeit von geier hatte aber so bisschen zwischen dem vorgänger lied von daher parkhaus auf dem wir vielleicht auch noch.
Nachher und äh gallia so 'n so 'ne runde zwischenlösung machen konnte und am ende scheiterte das an wenigen millionen.
Euro oder die die dann fehlten um dieses projekt zu realisieren aber ich war dann schon mal drin in diesem dieser astronomie trier und hab dann auch so ein bisschen die spannung die das dahinter steckt gemerkt
und dann bin ich dann zweitausendvier schließlich in,
heidelberg gelandet um dann wirklich mit garcia zu beschäftigen das heißt aus zweitausendvier das war neun jahre vom start äh hab ich dann angefangen wirklich
direkt für scania projekt zu arbeiten hatte aber natürlich durch das projekt schon auch einige grundkenntnisse über die dinge die mit der astronomie im weltraum astronomie zusammenhängen.
Dann schauen wir doch mal sozusagen auf auf diese ausgangslage also.
Haben wir ja schon angesprochen.
Den die himmelskörper zu verstehen und ihren lauf meines war nun lange zeit auch so ein bisschen die kern debatte wie ist denn sozusagen jetzt dieses zentrum wenn 's überhaupt eins,
jetzt gibt's eigentlich nicht so richtig wir sind auf jeden fall nicht selbst wenn's eins gibt.
Nachdem das ja sagen wir mal zumindest wissenschaftlich jetzt alles bei seite geräumt wurde und wir generell ein ganz braucht bares grundverständnis der komplexität des als haben,
hat mir auch immer so 'n bisschen den eindruck na ja gut dann wissen wir ja bescheid was anderes machen aber ganz so einfach.
Ist es nicht was war jetzt die.
Notwendigkeit für diese mission was wollte man erreichen was man bis dahin noch nicht erreicht hat was haben vorgänger mission in diesem in der gastronomie trier also konkret wahrscheinlich parkhaus.
Überhaupt bisher schon ein grundlagen geschafft.
Ja also erstmal gab's natürlich die boden gebundene astronomie trier wo man dann mit hilfe von teleskopen die sterne gegenseitig vermessen haben und ähm das was die astronomie trixie
im wesentlichen liefert die was interessant ist für die wissenschaft sind außer der position die direkt ja mit dem wort astronom betrieb der messung zu tun hat auch deren bewegung am himmel und
was ganz ganz fundamental wichtig ist für das verständnis der sterne die entfernung der sterne und zwar kann man in jedem astronomie
buch nachschlagen dass es dutzende von methoden gibt mit dem man die entfernung von sternen messen kann aber
die meisten davon machen schon annahmen über die objekte die man vermessen will also sie sind nicht wirklich unabhängig von dem was man eigentlich machen möchte und die unabhängig die methode die geht zurück dass man das er zum ersten mal
achtzehnhundert achtunddreißig gemessen hat wenn ich das richtig.
In erinnerung habe jetzt muss ich das müsste eigentlich am liebsten nochmal nachgucken achtzehn achtunddreißig als friedrich wilhelm bessere von königs berg in ostpreußen aus zum ersten mal eine parallel axse eine sterns gemessen hat und
das ist eine geometrischen methode mit der man die einfahrt roter stern messen kann diese idee die gibts schon viel viel länger aber.
In jahre achtzehn achtunddreißig war's denn.
Möglich das mit hilfe von teleskopen und einem sehr ausgeklügelten instrument und eine ausgeklügelten technik zu vermessen das,
nämlich dahinter dass sich die erde ja um die sonne bewegt und auf diesem weg legen wir natürlich eine gewisse strecke zurück
und wenn man jetzt einen stern anvisierten im laufe eines jahres immer wieder dann haben die sterne die der erde relativ nah sind.
Verschieben sich ein bisschen weil wir nämlich einen etwas anderen blickwinkel darauf haben dass es ähnlich wie wenn sie
ähm sagen wir mal mit dem auto dann im zug durch die landschaft fahren dann sind objekte die in näher sind bewegen sich natürlich viel schneller als die die im hintergrund sind also vom winkel her von der bewegung die scheinbaren bewegung.
Ja die berge sind halt fix aber die masten der strom trasse die fliegen halt an einem vorbei.
Die fliegen also richtig an einem vorbei und so ähnlich ist das im prinzip eine sterne dass die verdammt viel weiter weg sind das heißt dass sie alle.
Spielen 'ne rolle deshalb braucht man eben auch sehr ausgeklügelte techniken um das zum ersten mal zu machen und gleichzeitig kommt noch als komplikation dazu hinzu dass die sterne sich auch noch bewegen während dieser zeit ist also nicht nur diese
palacio effekt sondern während wir durch die landschaft fahren äh kann man sich vorstellen dass es da eben nicht die stromkosten sind sondern sie selber bewegende andere autos oder so die von deren geschwindigkeit man gleichzeitig auch noch bestimmen möchte oder muss damit man das ganze äh haben kann und vor allen dingen
dass die winkel unglaublich klein sind also für
die nächsten stern alpha centauri oder das ist nur einer der komponenten dieses doppel dieses mehrfach systems auf besteht aus drei stern,
dass es vier komma drei lichtjahre entfernt und die paar lachse dieser winkel um die sich das.
Bewegung der erde um die sonne verschiebt die ist die will dies deutlich weniger als eine bogen sekunden eine bogen sekunde das ist der dreitausendsechshundert eines grades also das sind schon sehr kleine winkel und.
Das heißt also um entfernung von zu sterben mit dieser geometrischen methode zu messen
braucht man eine unheimlich hohe messgerät neuigkeit und die war eben für die allerletzten sterne erreicht so im.
Ja anfang bis ende bis mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts aber das ging dann.
Das war 's natürlich nötig wenn man jetzt ein bisschen weiter weg geht dass man da für eine höhere genauigkeit braucht und deshalb hat man dann in den achtziger jahren den parkhaus satelliten.
In den weltraum geschossen der etwas mehr als hunderttausend sterne hoch genau vermessen hat
und die genauigkeit wenn man das mal sich überlegt die ist eine million sekunde das ist ein tausend eines einer bogen sekunde also dass also dreihundertsechzig
tausendste eines grades das sind also ganz kleine winkel die man da messen muss damit man die entfernung von sternen messen kann.
Und äh gleichzeitig eben wie gesagt bewegen sich die sterne auch durchaus in diesem zeitraum das heißt also muss dann auch noch gucken welche bewegung des sterns kommt jetzt von seiner bewegung durch den raum
und welche kommt durch diese scheinbare bewegung die durch die bewegung des observatorium um die sonne herum kommt.
Nicht nur um die sonne herum sondern auch das ganze sonnensystem als solches bewegt.
Bewegt sich auch noch das heißt also wir müssen immer davon ausgehen dass wir uns natürlich selber ähm in einem bewegten system befinden aber
das also relativ zur erde sozusagen kann man's dann erstmal messen aber da muss man natürlich gucken wie bewegt sich dieser sonnensystem relativ zu den anderen stern das ist natürlich auch eben eine.
Also wir fahren nicht nur im zug wir laufen auch noch in dem zug hin und her.
Ganz genau genau und dann wenn man das alles anvisierten wird ein vielleicht klar wie kompliziert das ganze ist aber
auch wie nötig das ganze ist warum ist das denn ja so wichtig dass man solche besserung macht das liegt daran dass man
von einem sternen ja zum beispiel sowas wie sessel helligkeit von der erde aus messen kann.
Und da wissen wir also wie viele proton kommen auf der erde an wie viel energie kommt auf der erde an aber was uns eigentlich wirklich interessiert ist
wie funktioniert so ein stern und da gibt es dann ja auch modelle und da kann man ausrechnen in unseren modellen wie viel energie wörter ab gestrahlt von so einem stern und.
Das weiß man natürlich nur wenn man weiß wie weit die weit dieser stern entfernt ist also wenn man jetzt nehmen wir mal alle glück die lampe nimmt die in,
in einer bestimmten entfernung steht die wir aber nicht kennen dann wissen wir wie viel licht.
Auf unserem foto detektor ankommen sagen wir mal aber wir wissen nicht ob die lampe jetzt besonders hell ist oder diese lampe besonders nah ist wenn wir keine entfernung information haben und damit man sterne versteht braucht man also
eine eine idee wie weit diese stern entfernt sind und am besten nicht nur eine idee
sondern da wird man das wirklich hochpräzise mit den genauen modelle die wir heute haben vergleichen kann braucht man wirklich sehr präzise messung
und deshalb ist es eben umso besser je genauer diese messung sind dass wir die energie strahlung zum beispiel des sterns von
von von der oberfläche aussehen können und und mit den modellen vergleichen kann.
Ja so ein bisschen besser mit der der taschenlampe im dunkeln von der waren halt auch nicht weiß wo er sie kommt oder überhaupt generell wenn man ein auge zu kneift und es geht einfach das drei dimensionale verloren hab ich halt nur noch einen einzigen beobachtung punkt und braucht halt noch ein zweites
idealfall ist aber noch ein bisschen mehr augen um sozusagen diese unterschiede der position auch überhaupt erst wahrnehmen.
Genau also ich meine genau das ist auch so die veranschaulichen eine paradoxe dass man zum beispiel sein sein
den daumen an der hand ausstreckt und sich mal anguckt wo ist der daumen von linken auge ausgesehen relativ zu dem hintergrund den man sieht,
dann nimmt man das andere auge und dann sieht man dass das natürlich so einen sprung gibt und wenn man den daumen weiter entfernt stellt äh also die hand weiter ausstreckt.
Sieht man dass dieser winkel kleiner wird und das ist nur in diesem fall ist es so dass die
der augenabstand dann sozusagen dreihundert millionen kilometer beträgt das ist nämlich das was die erde in einem halben jahr von der einen seite seines ihres arbeits äh bis zur anderen seite zurückliegt und das ist dann was man basis linie nennt und von diesen beiden blick punkten aus wie sieht man denn ein stern an und der halbe winkel die nennt man diesen paradoxen winken und
ähm.
Das pascal ja dann natürlich machen sollte ist dass es nicht dass es diesen winkel dann noch viel genauer misst dass man nicht mehr dann in nienburg sekunden geht.
Sondern in die mikro bogen sekunden geht das ist also so dass die besten besserung sowas wie zwanzig fünfundzwanzig mikro bogen sekunden betragen mikrofon sekunde das millionsten bogen sekunden also das entspricht ungefähr.
Ein winkel wenn man den messen würde in der entfernung des mondes wir gucken zwar die mut nicht an also das ist jetzt nur im vergleich,
wenn man da eine lampe hätte die sich im laufe eines jahres um sagen wir mal vier fünf zentimeter verschiebt.
Und wir würden das im laufe der zeit immer mal wieder mit gallia anvisieren was wir nicht tun aber für uns nur mal angenommen dann würden wir diese bewegung messen können mit gar ja
für die endgültigen katalog also von der erde ausgesehen ne das ist ja sozusagen der vergleich das heißt also da
oder flagge wir haben über apollo geredet die aus astronauten aufstellen da gehen wir davon aus dass vielleicht der abstand da so ein paar zentimeter sind dass man die sozusagen den abstand.
Oder die verschiebung von einem stern zum anderen messen würde dann äh von der erde ausgesehen das ist natürlich jetzt nur eine nur der analogie aber das zeigt die klein diese winkel sind.
Damit man wirklich gute astrophysik betreiben will braucht man diese präzision und das ist auch der grund warum die astronom wirklich äh
darauf auf galeria gewartet haben und ähm und zwar alle gebiete der astrophysik kann man im prinzip davon nachher profitiert das ist wirklich das ganze.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur die die gesteigerte präzision die geier jetzt mit sich bringt sondern ist auch andere beobachtung und ähm auch eine viel größere betrachtung.
Ja also die größere genauigkeit ist das eine und in der tat ist es
viel licht schwächere objekte mit gaia beobachten kann als mit dem parkhaus sat liter wie gesagt hunderttausend zweihunderttausend hellsten sterne etwa beobachtet hat und wir können inzwischen
mit garcía haben wir in dem katalog bei dem der wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen genauer sprechen werden eins komma sieben
milliarden sterne drin für die position gemessen haben und für eins komma drei milliarden von den stern haben wir auch deren entfernung und deren bewegung,
vermessen und ähm so ein stern ähm jetzt wie weit geht das sozusagen wie nicht schwach kann ein stern seine mit davon gar ja noch gemessen wird dass es entspricht etwa.
Eine kerze in etwa dreißigtausend kilometer entfernung wenn ein stern so hell ist wie 'ne kerze in dreißigtausend kilometer entfernung von uns.
Dann entspricht das das was von zwanzig oder zwanzig komma siebte größe nennt dass es für den größten einteilung übrigens von einem griechischen astronom namen die paar stammt hundertfünfzig vor christian hat er nämlich einen stern katalog gemacht und er hat nicht nur,
der war sozusagen eine der ersten astro meter dies dies dann gehabt der astronomie try wirklich gemacht hat und er hat nicht nur die startposition vermessen mit
bloßen auge und natürlich.
Mit unserem heutigen vergleichst maßstäben aber der hat auch die helligkeit angegeben er hat nämlich gesagt die helfen sterne nicht erste größe und die die mich gerade noch mit bloßem auge sehen kann das sind sechste größe.
Und gastronom sind wirklich die konservativen wissenschaftler dies auf der ganzen erde gibt.
Woran sieht man das dass wir dieses system von grüßen klassen was er mal eingeführt hat auch heute noch benutzen das haben wir jetzt erweitert ins negative also unsere sonne zum beispiel hat minus sechsundzwanzigste.
In diesem system und.
Die lichtschächte objekte die man so mit den allergrößten teleskopen noch sehen kann die haben neunundzwanzigste dreißigste größe und mit
mist nun einfach alle sterne die ähm heller sind als diese größe diese.
Das.
Diese methode genau magnet tour deine größten klasse nennt man das und ähm
die ganz heißen sterne machen bisschen problem weil da ja die kriegen wir nicht so gut hin also die alle helfen sterne die man in einer stadt wie berlin äh mit bloßem auge sehen kann die kriegen wir leider nicht hin da sind immer noch am besten mit markus gemessen.
Also weil die so über strahlen das dann wiederum das feine äh instrumentarium einfach über überschlägt.
Genau genau wir haben also sind da sind die tief detektor und dann gesättigt wie man sagt also.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht so das problem weil die können wir dann wiederum auch hat man wahrscheinlich mit dem parkhaus schon gut genug gesehen oder können wir mit anderen methoden gut genug sehen.
Sie sind relativ gut vermessen parkhaus sowie hätten sie gerne noch heller und vielleicht gibt 's sogar 'ne chance dass man mit ein paar tricks
nachher auch die hellsten sterne noch ein bisschen genau ermessen kann mit mit gar ja aber im moment ist die
sozusagen grenz größe für diejenigen die mit diesem begriff das andere anfangen können so dritte größe also sterne die helle sind als dritte größe die werden wir erstmal nicht bekommen vielleicht mit ein paar schlauen tricks können wir an den hand der daten nachher doch nochmal was machen da werden so ganz spezielle aufnahmen gemacht wo es aber noch nicht genügend leute gibt die sich damit beschäftigen die sind nämlich.
Drin in der in dem
prozession deren um die auch die nächsten katalog jetzt fertig zu machen da ist im moment gar keine manpower und wo man power da um das wirklich äh hinzubekommen aber vielleicht in zukunft kann man da vielleicht noch was machen und die helfen sterne werden schon
sehr interessant weil sie natürlich die best an auf anderen gebieten immer die best vermessung sterne sind natürlich die
die uns auch am hellsten erscheinen und wenn man die noch ein bisschen präziser hinweg käme wäre schon toll aber das was geier macht es wirklich großartig wir wir schaffen's also
fast schon an diese äh diese prognostizierte
genauigkeit zu kommen von der echter sprach mit dem zweiten stern katalog da sind wir haben noch ein paar probleme dass die dass das so systematische kleine fehler drin sind man macht ja immer mehr fehler man darf das ist eine der dinge die immer ganz wichtig sind das macht verwirrt auch viele die sich vielleicht so wissenschaftlich damit nicht so beschäftigen ganz wichtig ist immer zu wissen.
Welche messe fehler mache ich also wenn man mit einem zentimeter maß irgendwas mist weiß jeder genau das kann ich vielleicht auch 'n kilometer oder 'n halben millimeter genau etwas messen und dann bei stern muss man das genauso machen dass man muss wissen
wie groß ist die parallel axel plus minus wie viel und da sind wir daran arbeiten daran am arbeiten noch,
zu gucken ob da vielleicht so kleine verschiebung drin sind gegenüber dem was man hat das ist also sage die detailarbeit die aber fürchterlich viel mühe gemacht bei so.
Aber es geht ja nicht nur um sterne es geht ja im prinzip um alles was man sehen kann und wenn man jetzt eine höhere auflösung nicht auflösen sagen wir mal eine höhere lichtempfindlichkeit instrumenten hat dann.
Sich ja auch das eine oder andere objekt vielleicht noch äh dazwischen was brauchbar beleuchtet wird.
Ja oder was von selber leuchtet natürlich dass es im wesentlichen haben.
Aber so auch australien und kompetent und so weiter die fliegen doch auch rum.
Oh das das ist richtig da gibt es ähm ja die asteroiden dann in der tat auch gemessen weil sie genau wie alle sterne scheinbar für das instrument sowas ich erstmal.
Quellen sind hier also nicht man wo man nicht weiter auflösen kann und äh alle punkt quellen werden im prinzip von gallia gemessen das sagt sogar die elektronik an bord die
nach wo in welchem bereich und so meines messe instrument es ist so ein objekt und da gibt es natürlich objekte die zu unserem sonnensystem gehören wie die asteroiden und da ist.
Spannend dass man dass wir in dem zweiten stern katalog auch beobachtung daten von vierzehntausend asteroiden drin haben.
Und jetzt sind sogar von garcia zum ersten mal drei neue entdeckt worden das ist jetzt noch nicht so 'ne riesen zahl aber das das ist auch besonders
bei gar ja neue entdeckungen dazu machen weil das war gar nicht jetzt sagen wir mal ein astrid mehrere tage miteinander messen kann und dann werden wir uns machen möchte nochmal macht sondern geier hat ein ganz klares konzept wie der himmel abgetastet wird welche teil des himmels zu welchem zeitpunkt
beobachtet wird und da sind die zeiträume so dass es dass wir das nicht sagen können wir uns interessiert jetzt grade diese astrid besonders dann um dessen bahn zu vermessen müsste man den noch häufiger haben sondern man musste dann wenn man den entdeckt hat.
Boden gebundenen instrument nochmal nachgucken das wo der jetzt hinfliegt.
Ne und äh aber das ist etwas was äh auch extrem spannend ist dass wir die durch die hohe präzision der geier messung.
Die bahn von asteroiden viel genauer hinbekommen als als wir's von erd gebundenen instrumenten machen können zumindest wenn wir die jetzt noch äh auch länger beobachten im laufe der mission.
Aber auch extra planeten können schon ausgemacht werden die ja man ja bisher eigentlich
ich weiß nicht ob's nur aber primär halt über so klassische exot planeten forschung also traditionen vor ihrem stern und den sie kreisen oder mehrere sterne vielleicht auch dass man eben dann entsprechende licht abschwächung messen kann über eine längere zeit also da hat ja mann
hitler vor allem natürlich dass dieses gruppe beharrlich über ein längeren zeitraum bestimmte bereiche beobachtet um solche nachweise zu machen.
Verstehe ich das richtig das auch in der lage ist die planeten jetzt direkt zu sehen.
Ein geiler kann diese planeten nicht direkt sehen weil die zu nah mutter sternen drangewöhnt und was aber gar ja messen kann ist auch da die indirekte bewegung die die sterne machen also es gibt ja
also die entdeckung der sterne
der ersten des ersten der ersten exakt planeten ging ja über eine methode die wackelt bewegung des haupt sterns ausnutzen also wenn äh nehmen wir mal an ein planet umkreist ein anderen stern dann ist es ja so dass dieser planet nicht um den anderen stern kreis sondern beide um den gemeinsamen schwer
punkt und das heißt also beide bewegen sich um diesen schwerpunkt der stern ist viel näher an diesem schwerpunkt als der viel weniger masse erreiche planet
und aber er macht trotzdem eine wackelt bewegung stellen wir uns mal vor äh unsere sonne würden wir von von weitem beobachten und
gucken was die machen würde weil ja.
Planeten in unserem sonnensystem sich um die sonne bewegen indem ihr euch an wir würden jetzt irgendwo auf einem fremden stern sein und wollten nachweisen dass in unserem sonnensystem planeten vorhanden sind das war vor allen dingen erstmal der jupiter das ist ja der.
Masse reichste planet und der wackelt ganz schön an der sonne herum aber auch die anderen planeten macht man das und ähm.
Was man messen würde wäre das der stern mehrere wackelt bewegung macht nämlich einmal
kommt ein bisschen auf uns zu und fliegt wieder von uns weg das kann man mit dem sogenannten doppelter effekt machen wenn man die
die wellenlänge des lichtes genau vermisst und die sogenannte spektral linien die man ähm ein licht im licht findet dann kann man sehen dass die
so ein bisschen verschoben sind zu längeren oder kürzeren wellenlänge und das ähm das entspricht so ein bisschen wie das was man aus dem alltag hin wenn ein.
Ja ein krankenwagen auf einen zukommt dann scheint die frequenz des scheiß von seiner matt von seinem von martin horn ähm höheren ton zu geben wenn ihr auf uns zukommt und 'n niedrigeren ton gibt's denn wenn er wieder von uns wegfliegt uns gleich
beim lichter wird also es liegt ein bisschen zuhören längeren wellenlänge oder zu kürzeren wellenlänge verschoben und nimmt das rot und blau verschiebung weil rot eben
für längere wellenlänge steht und blau für kürzere welt steht und das heißt diese kleine verschiebung die hat man dann
angefangen in den mitte der neunziger jahre so genau zu wissen dass man damit die ersten planeten entdeckt hat und das würde ein außerirdischer unseres sonnensystem beobachten würde sagen wir mal aus vielleicht dreißig vierzig lichtjahren entfernung.
Ganz genauso sehen.
Aber er würde dann sehen dass diese bewegung nicht der bewegung nur eines planeten entspricht sondern dass da zum beispiel der saturn als vielleicht als nächstes masse reiches objekt noch eine weitere bewegung macht und waren alles zusammenfasst ist es so dass der schwerpunkt der sonne.
Manchmal sogar ein bisschen außerhalb des radios liegt das heißt im moment ist das zum beispiel auch gerade so und ähm.
Mit gar ja können wir nun nicht so genau messen ob der stern auf uns zu davon weg kriegen sondern wir können die seitliche bewegung messen und diese seitliche hin und her wackeln der sonne.
Der würde von etwa dreißig lichtjahren entfernung in unserem sonnensystem etwa eine mili buchen sekunde entsprechend das wäre also grade.
Zu einer messgerät grenze von dem parkhaus satelliten wo ihr sagt ja das ist 'ne mili bogen sekunde also als tausend eines der bogen also 'ne tausend einer bogen sekunde die wieder um dreihundertsechzig.
Eines dreitausendsechshundert eines grades ist diese wackelt bewegung würde man grad noch messen aber gar ja hat ja eine viel höhere genauigkeit das heißt wir würden
diese wackelt bewegung sehr genau analysieren können und das können wir natürlich umgekehrt wenn wir jetzt auf der erde setze sind.
Für andere sterne auch machen da sehen wir also sagen die hin und her wackeln das hin und her wackeln tangente an der himmels faire das ist das was durch die position messung von ga.
So die hypothese dass wir wahrscheinlich einige zehntausend planeten von jupiter massen oder ein bisschen weniger auf diese weise
bekommen würden aber im
jetzigen stern katalog ist das noch nicht der fall also wir sind da noch nicht genau genug und haben vor allen dingen noch nicht lange genug gemessen um diese bewegung zu sehen denn.
Zweite stern katalog den wir ja im am,
am fünfundzwanzigsten april fünfundzwanzigsten april im jahr zweitausendachtzehn also letztes jahr veröffentlicht haben der äh.
Das basiert auf nur zweiundzwanzig monaten beobachtung zeit.
Jetzt haben wir im juli fünf jahre roman beobachtung das heißt wir haben schon viel mehr daten zusammen und die werden natürlich jetzt einfließen auch in den nächsten stein katalog der wird als ich aber auch noch nicht mit exakt planeten beschäftigen
da da wird es dann sozusagen der der übernächste katalog zum ersten mal äh daten für liefern und unsere hoffnung ist
dass wir mit gar ja ja sogar zehn jahre bestzeit am ende haben denn wir haben noch so viel reserven an bord dass man vielleicht 'ne zehn jahres mission draus machen kann.
Eigentlich sollte ja dieses jahr schluss sein ne.
Ganz genau und ähm wir haben jetzt schon 'ne verlängerung von anderthalb jahren das heißt bis ende zweitausendzwanzig kann wird gemessen werden technisch alles so in ordnung bleibt und danach ist als der plan der auch eigentlich von allen.
Akzeptiert ist aber natürlich offiziell wird das immer nur in scheiben von zwei jahren etwa genehmigt,
dann äh wird wird also die mission vielleicht bis zu fünf jahre verlängert denn wir haben genug.
Gas an bord mit dem man die geier ausrichten kann und diese um dieses gesetz am himmel sozusagen zu gewährleisten,
und äh wir haben also wir können also bis etwa zweitausenddreiundzwanzig vierundzwanzig messen und dann hat man zehn jahre an daten und könnte dann diese wackel bewegung natürlich noch viel genauer hinbekommen und diese wackelt bewegung.
Braucht natürlich 'ne zeit zum beispiel wenn man jetzt wieder die die unser sonnensystem von außen beobachten würde dann würde man ja sehen der jupiter braucht zwölf jahre.
Um einmal die sonne zu umkreisen das heißt in einem jahr oder zweiundzwanzigsten monat.
Macht er so 'n kleinen betrag nur dass man das kaum beobachten würde aber wenn man dann fünf oder zehn jahre hat dann kann man das natürlich sehr genau messen das heißt da hilft jede.
Verlängerung der mission ungemein um dann die daten noch genauer zu haben und noch mehr exakt planeten zu finden aber das ist noch zukunftsmusik was die exakt planeten angeht wenn man von einer sache absieht wenn ich das kurz mal sagen darf es gibt natürlich bekannte.
Um die zu verstehen ist es immer wichtig die entfernung des systems zu kennen denn ähm dann kann man auch dann viel mehr darüber schließen was es für mutter stern ist und wie.
Die durchmesser nachher der planeten sind auch bei den stern die vor allem sternen weglaufen diese transit planeten da da kriegt man dann relative
winkel aber wenn man die entfernung kennt dann kann man auch den durchmesser der planeten bestimmt das heißt schon jetzt helfen die geier daten für das gebiete exel planeten aber noch nicht um selber welche zu entdecken.
Man daraus dann wiederum die masse genauer berechnen kann und damit diesen einfluss auch in relation setzen kann.
Dieses beispiel mit dem wackelt mir fällt da immer als erstes so die über kopf.
Bei übertragung von leichtathletik festivals ein
wo hammer werfe am start da kann man das irgendwie sehr schön sehen ja also man sieht sozusagen den spieler oben der diesen hammer mit einer unfassbaren beschleunigung um sich herum macht aber man sieht
eiern wie einfach die kugel
die ja eigentlich gerade beschleunigt äh wird und man würde sagen es ist halt der hammer werfe oder die haben das halt äh leider aber genauso ist es ja auch die kugel die wiederum am menschen reist und damit eben dieses wackeln erzeugt.
Ganz genau das ist für den vergleich dass man da sieht die die umkreisen praktisch auch ein schwerpunkt wenn sie wenn wenn die beschleunigt werden.
Man merkt dass der halt nicht in der mitte ist ne und dadurch dieses eiern entsteht das war ja auch beim mond und erde haben also generell wenn's bei maaßen aufeinander treffen ist das halt immer.
Der fall wenn wir nochmal kurz bei den zielen.
Also sterne klar zu hell schwierig aber vielleicht irgendwann nochmal alles was er einer ist oder zumindest in unserem sonnensystem ausreden kometen trans methodischen objekte vermute ich.
Komm da auch mit ins spiel indirekt haben wir jetzt schon gehört exot planeten aber da natürlich auch schwache sterne die.
Sehr wenig licht ausstrahlen dürften jetzt sehr viel häufiger gefunden werden können als das vorher der fall war,
aber es geht ja auch ein bisschen über die milchstraße hinaus gibt ja auch durchaus galaxien die äh recht hell daher strahlen die sollte man ja dann eigentlich auch noch in den fokus nehmen.
Ja die
komm mal kann man auch in den fokus nehmen und wir können tatsächlich bei den namen galaxien einzelne helle sterne sehen die sind nämlich heller als die größte klasse die ansprache also heller als 'ne kerze in dreißigtausend kilometer entfernung sind zum beispiel einige sterne im android meter nebel aber ganz besonders interessant sind.
Unsere direkten nachbarn unsere milchstraße ist ja umgeben von vielen kleineren galaxien sogenannten zwerg galaxien die um sie herum kreisen.
Und da sieht man da kann man äh zum beispiel bei dem aller nächsten milchstraße der großen wolke da da hat man viele sterne vermessen deren bewegung und rotation mann um den
um der um ein zentrum herum man direkt beobachten kann anhand der galeria daten in zweiundzwanzig monaten tatsächlich ist es so dass die galaxie alle zu weit weg sind als das man deren entfernung mit hilfe der parallel.
Bei genauigkeit messen könnte aber die bewegung die da drin sind sind so groß dass man das machen kann und tatsächlich ist das erste
hey was in dem ersten stern katalog herausbekommen ist im september zweitausendsechzehn.
Eins gewesen dass ich mit der rotation von stern in der großen maryland nischen wolke eine des unser nachbar zweck galaxien messen ist.
Also volker heißt nicht deshalb weil man früher halt dass wir ein wirbel nebel oder eine wolke wahrgenommen hat aber später hat man festgestellt sind auch nur sterben.
Es ist in wirklichkeit in galaxy die eben auch aus vielen millionen sterben besteht und damals hat man achtundzwanzig sterne.
Verbessern können mit hilfe dieses ersten stern katalog s da hat man die bewegung schon gesehen und jetzt sieht man sowas wie,
millionen sterne die man veganer gemessen hat wie sie einzeln um die sind alles die hälfte sterne in der in diesem diesem system und da kann man dann sehr hoch genau
wie die sterne sich da bewegen zumindest tangente sozial da musste man dann nochmal bei einigen stern auch nach beobachtet wird man auch noch die bewegung auf uns zu davon uns weg mit diesem
doppelter effekt den ich ja vorhin erwähnt hatte noch hinzu bekommt dann kann man wirklich deren raum bewegung auch ganz genau studieren und das ist also eine der sachen die man machen kann und tatsächlich ist es sogar so dass meine andeutung äh von der,
bewegung und auch der rotation auch in unseren nachbar galaxien der der der sandro meter neben den man ja auch
ganz knapp noch mit bloßen auge sehen kann und in einer anderen genauen galaxy s m dreiunddreißig heißt die messen kann das heißt also so weit äh reichen die daten und wenn man die zehn jahre oder fünf jahre auch nur nachher
ausgewertet hat.
Dann kann man deren bewegung schon sehr genau messen und bei der andere medaille galaxy ist zum beispiel sehr interessant weil die in einigen milliarden jahren mit.
Die sehr sehr nahe an die milchstraße herankommt und man sagt sie miteinander kollidiert das heißt also die
die werden dann gravitation die schwerkraft der beiden galaxien die wird auf die sterne sowohl in der milchstraße als auch in der in der nebel einfluss haben sodass die sterne ziemlich durcheinandergewirbelt werden dadurch und ähm durch die messung
ein bisschen berechnung wie solche umeinander funktionieren,
wird man auch dann irgendwie herausfinden wie genau das in drei vier milliarden jahren ablaufen wird das ganze wenn wir das haben im moment gibt es so ein kleiner hinweis darauf wie das line wird aber mit den genauen daten,
hat man auch sozusagen diese zukünftige kollision zwischen unseren beiden galaxien äh hoch genau untersuchen kann.
Wobei da nicht wirklich was kollidieren wird wahrscheinlich sondern es schiebt sich mehr so ineinander und beeinflusst sich dann äh aber.
Genau also die sterne
da so viel platz dazwischen dass sie nicht direkt aufeinander prallen aber sie werden die bahn werden enorm voneinander beeinflusst werden das gilt es beobachtet man ja auch an fernen galaxien dass die miteinander solche austausch haben wo die zusammen fliegen dass die also da nicht mehr
ja so 'ne flache spirale galaxien wo die meisten in einer ebene sich befinden äh haben,
die sterne ins haben sondern dass die ganz toll durcheinandergewirbelt werden am ende das also auch etwas was man extra galaktisch sagen kann das heißt man kann die bahn oder suche und man wird auch wenn man weiter misst die genauere rotation der sterne um ihre,
ihr zentrum ähm dann auch sehr genau schon untersuchen kann.
Und da ist ja auch einiges an ministerien noch zu entschlüsseln ich hatte hier in rom zeit dreiundsechzig mit markus
brücken gesprochen über galaxien kostenlos und natürlich dann auch das ministerium der dunklen materie weil ja die astronomie trixie oder überhaupt die astronomische forschung herausgefunden hat ja okay alles klar wir wissen in etwa wie so 'ne galaxy sich dreht nur wir können 's halt mit unserem
vorstellung der gravitation die es hier eigentlich vielfach bewährt hat wenn das sozusagen alles stimmt dann passt das halt nicht und jetzt könnte man ja im prinzip
dadurch dass man jetzt den android-auto also sozusagen relativ nahe galaxien von dem man jetzt sehr viele sterne beobachten kann
wo wir wir sehen zwar viele sterne aber wir haben ja schwierigkeiten die ganze milchstraße zu sehen einfach weil sie sich selbst äh blockiert
jetzt hätte man ja sozusagen die möglichkeit hier auch diese modelle zu überarbeiten.
Ja also für die sogenannte dunkle materie der dahinter steckt spielt das natürlich eine große rolle also die bewegung der sterne wird natürlich durch ihre
momentane geschwindigkeit gegeben und dann die anziehungskraft aller anderen
masse reichen körper in einer in einer skala x y wie unsere milchstraße oder auch im android der nebel oder den anderen galaxien und diese bewegung da hat man festgestellt dass die in den äußeren bereichen viel schneller ist als mans bekommen würde wenn man die masse zusammenzählt die man sich
in einer galaxy hat und diese bewegung wird kann man natürlich mit gaia in sowohl unsere milchstraße als auch in den
nahe galaxien viel genauer untersuchung und dazu braucht man da noch modelle die einem etwas sagt wie groß das gravitation potential ist also da wird man dann auch
bessere hinweise bekommen wie diese äh wie die gravitation in unserem milchstraße system wirklich aussieht und dann auch äh aussagen darüber bekommen wie zum beispiel das verhältnis von
der der bekannten materie zu dieser sogenannten dunklen materie ist also da wird's mit sicherheit.
Da gibt's auch jetzt schon untersuchung die in diese richtung gehen aber das wird man natürlich mit den weiteren daten noch sehr viel genauer überprüfen können und auch an solchen zwerg galaxien wo
wo die ja zum beispiel teilweise weniger materie oder mehr materie enthalten und manche
nach dem modellen äh auch weniger oder mehr dunkle materie enthalten da kann man dann auch die unterschiede zwischen diesen objekten am ende mit gegen gallia daten
genauer analysieren es gibt ja auch immer noch ein paar leute die sagen es gibt diese dunkle materie gar nicht sondern wir kennen das gravitation gesetz noch nicht genügend
ich glaube wenn man das äh durch x dass das wahrscheinlich nicht die erklärung ist aber man sollte immer offen bleiben auch solche dinge zu gucken und wenn der beweis da wäre dass das mit der dunkle materie nicht hinhaut sondern mit den anderen plausibel ist dann
sollte man sich natürlich auch wieder belehren lassen dabei das wichtig ist deshalb eine grundlage für solche argumentation zu schaffen und da hilft natürlich die geier mission mit dem
präzisen daten die nicht nur die astronomie trier umfassen sondern zum beispiel auch die helligkeit und die farben der sterne natürlich ungemein.
Ich hab ja gesehen es gibt also nicht dass wir so zwei drei galaxien sehen sondern auch eher so im bereich von hunderttausend.
Ja ja wir sehen viele galaxien aber die die messung von
dass wir die bewegung zum beispiel in einer galaxy messen oder die bewegung der galaxien selber das wird nur für die nahen galaxien funktionieren also das äh die fans werk galaxien und die.
Ein paar größere galaxien in unserer lokale gruppe nennen also die nächsten millionen lichtjahre rund um unsere milchstraße herum können wir natürlich damit genauer untersuchen.
Dann schauen wir doch mal vielleicht kurz auf die.
Konkrete technik die jetzt hier zum einsatz kommt um diese ziele er jetzt im prinzip schon teilweise mit vorweggenommen ergebnissen formuliert haben.
Wie ist dieses äh diesen raum sondern dieses gerät
konzipiert worden ich glaub der ursprüngliche ansatz wurde auch mal äh verworfen wie es alles funktionieren soll was was steckt in diesem gerät um diese ziele zu erreichen.
Ja also erstmal warum geht man eigentlich in den weltraum das liegt daran dass man dort 'ne ruhigere messung umgebung hat und wenn man auf der
keine atmosphäre keine keines heißen bewegung keine keine rolle rotation all das äh das haben wir nicht.
Man kann überall hingucken.
Man kann überall hingucken das ist also 'ne ganz ganz wesentliche
wie sicher grund und mit parkhaus hat man das ja dann getestet dass das gut funktioniert da hat man ein nehmen wir übrigens ursprünglich mal eine stationäre bahn bringen wollte dann hat aber ein motor versagt und das war 's nachher in einer elektrischen bahn um die erde ist dieser sache.
Ja stabilisiert worden und hat dann die messung gemacht die am ende.
Praktisch so gut waren wie man das auch auf einer stationären bahn gehabt hätte man hätte hat ja große angst dass das ding dann gar nicht funktioniert richtig.
Aber man war noch relativ nah dran an der erde.
Wenn man war noch relativ genauer an.
Blockiert zwar nicht das meister aber immerhin noch einen signifikanteren teil des.
Genau und dass diese störung die sieht man natürlich auch in den beobachtungen daten also das die gravitation zum beispiel die ist ja sehr
in homogen also die erde ist nicht nur eine kugel die ganz homogen aufgebaut und ein ganz klares gravitationswellen hat sondern da sind ja gebirge die.
Weltweit ist die kartoffel die form der erde das wissen natürlich viel besser als ich es ist.
Ja ähm sehr kompliziert und dann ist auch die ausstrahlung die thermische ausstrahlung von der erde die geht mir viel auf dem satelliten und und sorgt dafür dass dafür formung 'ne rolle spielen und,
bei der messe genauigkeit von parkhaus konnte man das sehr gut heraus rechnen aber bei gaia hat man gesagt wir müssen erstmal möglichst weit weggehen von der erde und deshalb hat man.
Was ja als ich nicht so schwierig werden aber man will ja damit auch noch kommunizieren.
Man muss noch kommunizieren das ist übrigens auch ein ganz ganz wesentlicher grund für diese um konfiguration wie man am anfang von geil hatte ich auch gleich komme also man hat sich dann überlegt man geht eins komma fünf millionen kilometer weg von der erde das ist etwa die dreieinhalb fache entfernung zum mond
und das ist ein punkt den man krank punkt l zwei nennt das ist einer von fünf.
Im mit rotierende bezug system eines von von der sonne und einem der erde zum beispiel ähm
wo ein dritter körper zum beispiel gar ja dann in sicheren gleichgewicht befindet und man kann der ist der ist im falle von l zwei.
Eins komma fünf millionen kilometer weiter weg von der sonne als die erde.
Ein prozent die entfernung zur sonne ist ja seht ihr hundertfünfzig millionen kilometer also ein prozent weiter.
Dieser sogenannte punkt zwei und dort ist es so dass wir da nicht nur die äh dass dieser liter nicht wie bei den meisten planeten vor allen dingen die anziehungskraft der.
Der sonne nur spürt sondern auch die erde die ja die soziale immer zwischen diesem krank punkt und der sonne steht die stehen auf einer linie
und das heißt äh dadurch hat man gespürt diese satelliten höhere anziehungskraft und es muss kompensiert werden dadurch dass man ein bisschen weiter weggeht eben dieses ein prozent weiter weggeht man kann sagen die pflegekraft ist dann.
Größer so dass das grade ausgleicht ländlichen wird und dieser punkt l zwei des der ist auch sehr populär für andere.
Kostenlose spielplatz derzeit.
Genau da kommt auch dann hin und jetzt hier diese rosita.
Das ist ein sehr populärer platz weil der einfach von störung von der erde sehr sehr weit entfernt ist.
Trotzdem halt auch noch in einem also erstmal immer in der mehr oder weniger selben im selben abstand äh und dann eben auch noch kommunikativ ganz gut zu erreichen.
Ganz genau also man braucht eine verbindung denn es ist ja gar nichts das schöne daten wisst wie man dann hinterher nicht bekommt und in umlaufbahn ist es natürlich sehr leichter sind die braucht man auch keine riesigen antennen um mit zu kommunizieren braucht.
Fünfunddreißig meter große antennen und die haben die erreichen dann am ende,
eine betraten von acht megabit pro sekunde ungefähr also das was schlechte internet pro weiter bei uns auf der erde hinkriegen.
Genau wenn überhaupt manchmal naja jetzt wird's zu dem zu der technik also parkhaus hatte schon ein ganz wichtiges prinzip nämlich zweite des koppe an bord die in etwas verschiedene richtungen guck
und dann wurden messung gemacht damals noch mit hilfe von foto metern wenn die sterne denn durch die
pokal ebene des satelliten ging und bei daher hat man sich dann ursprünglich ein anderes konzept ausgedacht dass man ein sogenanntes meter bauen würde dass es bin ich gar nicht so ganz genau drauf eingehen dass es auf jeden fall etwas wo die.
Wo die wellen eigenschaften des des lichtes ausgenutzt werden um kleine verschiebungen zu zu.
Vermessen zu können und deshalb hat gar ja auch ihren namen bekommen nämlich das geil es war ursprünglich global also globales astro metallisches in der meter für die astrophysik.
Und.
Dieses prinzip wer zwar sehr gut gewesen aber man hat dann herausgefunden dass wenn man die daten zur erde übertragen würde man,
eigentlich nur die hälfte sterne dann damit messen könnte und dann hat man sich überlegt bei dieser.
Warum weil die eigene kommunikation.
Ja weil weil man ungefähr auf diese acht megabit pro sekunde angewiesen ist und man mehr daten braucht wenn man ein interview frische messung braucht dann braucht man pro stern viel mehr daten um um diese dieses diese
konstruktive und destruktiver verena ich will das wie gesagt wenn sie
wissen wollen kann ich es auch nochmal genauer erklären aber auf jeden fall ist es so dass es viel mehr daten erfordert solch eine interview frische messung zu machen so dass man sich dann überlegt hat nein so ein konventionelles teleskop auch wenn es schon sehr spezielles.
Ist eigentlich überlegen und dann hat man sich aber gesagt jetzt haben wir uns an den namen gar ja schon gewöhnt und dann ist da eben keinen,
ronny mehr gewesen keine abkürzungen gewesen sondern da heißt einfach nur gar ja eigentlich ein bisschen ungünstig weil,
ja ja ja der die köchin ist und die erde beobachten wir zum beispiel überhaupt nicht denn so in die nähe der erde steht die sonne von gala ausgesehen und wir
gucken immer mindestens fünfundvierzig grad weg von der sonne damit wir das
das ist sehr konstant eingehalten wird dass man da nicht näher rankommt und äh deshalb ist der name einfach nur nett aber.
Na ja gut aber ich meine es steht ja für die die uhr mutter und man könnte ja jetzt sagen ok jetzt zusammen über die erde auch hinausgewachsen wir wissen es gibt noch mehr die mutter ist sozusagen unser universe.
Genau und unsere erde ist natürlich auch eingeprägt bettelt in der sonnensystem und in den in die milchstraße so dass man wenn man wissen will was auf der erde geschieht natürlich auch die kostenlosen einflüsse nicht vernachlässigen kann also man kann das immer natürlich diesen bogen soweit ziehen wie man.
Wir wollen diesen namen jetzt bye-bye.
Ganz genau und deshalb deshalb muss man auch gar ja vorne mit dem großen schreiben und dann den rest klein schreiben also es ist also es wird immer noch vor selbst von vielen astrophysik falsch gemacht in papers.
Na ja gut das haben wir das geringste problem wie es heißt hauptsache es funktioniert also was ist denn jetzt stattdessen drin.
Da sind jetzt zwei teleskope drin die recht eckige das im spiegel teleskope die übrigens aus einem material hergestellt werden was ich
das ist ein sehr hartes material sehr leichtes material für raum fahrzeuge also sehr geeignet.
Weil man natürlich masse im weltraum zu transportieren das ist ja das was ruhe große rakete dann erfordert und
der hauptstadt hat zwei haupt spiegel die in zwei verschiedene richtung gucken und die das recht eckige spiegel die größe von ein meter fünfundvierzig mal fünfzig zentimeter haben das sind also so die haupt instrumente die das licht sammeln sind hohe spiegel die also das licht sammeln aber damit nicht genug insgesamt hat man zehn spiegel.
Die am ende
das licht auf eine kamera auf unsere lichtempfindlich inspektoren sogenannte cd sektoren werfen und dort äh die entsprechenden messung machen und zwar
das eine von der eine von denen bis bald eine von den beiden teleskopen in eine richtung am himmel und das andere teleskop gleichzeitig an eine richtung die hundert sechs einhalb grad.
Eine andere richtung ist das heißt wir messen das hat viel parkhaus auch schon gemacht mit etwas anderen winkel aber wir gucken in zwei richtung.
Der winkel egal oder ist das jetzt wirklich äh hat sich irgendwas ergebnis eine rein konstruktive geschichte was reinpasst.
Bei beides es gibt ein paar konstruktive und ingenieur technische gründe warum man nicht jeden winkel nehmen würdest kommen aber viele winkel in frage am besten muss das ein winkel sein der kein
kein klein teiler hat mit äh mit dreihundertsechzig grad also kein dieser winkel ein vielfaches davon darf nicht irgendwie so was wie dreihundertsechzig grad sein und
da gibt's ein paar weitere mathematische gründe warum man den jetzt ausgewählt hat aber da kommen im prinzip mehrere solche winkel in frage und.
Das ist eins ein ganz wesentliches prinzip mit dem man nämlich ähm sozusagen kleinen räume.
Relative messungen zwischen winkel verschiebung zwischen zwei.
Genauso messen kann wie großräumig also mit einem normalen teleskope hat man immer ein gewisses gesichts feld das hat mir bestimmte größe das heißt man bist.
Objekt die in diesem gesichts feld gerade zu sehen sind und mit diesem prinzip hat man ein zweites gesichts feld was auch gleichzeitig gemessen wird und so hat man dann winkel abstände die über hundert sechs komma fünf grad hinaus.
Gleichzeitig
mit den messung von objekt die nur aus dem ein oder den anderen gesichts feld kommen und das hilft dann um sozusagen am ende 'ne die relativen
winkel zwischen den stern auch über den gesamten himmel zu messen und für die experten wenn diese winkel absolut stabil.
Wäre leider ist es das nicht ganz genau das ist eins der kleine probleme die man bei so einer raumfahrt missionen am ende erkennt wenn der winkel ganz genau konstant wäre dann könnte man
den sogenannten nullpunkt der parallel axel genau bestimmen denn eines der punkte bei dieser paradoxen methode die ich ansprach ist ja
wann ist diese parallel axel null was entspricht einem unendlich weit entfernten objekt äh dass da wir ja sozusagen immer nur die relativen abstände zwischen den objekten machen die aber alle.
So eine relaxen bewegung machen ähm wo ist da der nullpunkt sozusagen und mit zwei gesichts feldern kann man das
kann man diesen nullpunkt finden das ist nämlich so dass diese parallele bewegung in dem ein gesichts fällt fällig andere richtung hat als in den anderen feld man kann es sogar so machen dass in dem einfällt es null wäre während es in anderen feld zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt im anderen feld
einen größeren betrag hat und deshalb kann man den nullpunkt mathematisch auf diese weise herausbekommen durch diese zweite.
Aber insgesamt ist das sehr hilfreich dass man auf diese weise sozusagen stabile astro militärische lösung über den gesamten himmel am ende erhält um daraus ein stern katalog aus den einzelnen beobachtung starten
zu konstruieren und diese anderen spiegel sind dazu da dass alles in eine kalte ebene zu finden und zu bringen wo unsere kamera drin ist die aus hundertsechs cd doktoren die lichtempfindlich direktorin sind
das aufgezeichnet wird insgesamt hat die kamera übrigens etwa ein gigawatt pixel zusammen und es damit immer noch die größte weltraum kamera was die anzahl der pixel angehen.
Ok
Das heißt die spiegel bringen da einfach viel licht äh zusammen dass eben dann auch noch aus zwei verschiedenen perspektiven und man hat ein extrem hoch auflösen c was also auch sagen wir mal heutige smartphones noch bei weitem über schreitet.
Ja also man hat eine sehr hohe messe genauigkeit auf diese weise und man muss dann gucken wo ist ein stern zu welchem zeitpunkt in der in der pokal ebene und aus diesem dieser messung müssen wir dann herausbekommen wo ist er am himmel und das ist.
Da dazu benutze übrigens ein atome uhr dass wir eben sagen wann ist äh läuft das stärkt das bild eines sterne es über unsere kamera und zu welchem zeitpunkt befindet sich dieser stern wo auf auf den cds.
Könnte man natürlich jetzt schlau fragen ja aber das funktioniert natürlich nur wenn ich weiß wo guckt eigentlich satt zu welchem zeitpunkt ganz genau hin und.
Nun wenn man sich ein bisschen mit mit satelliten beschäftigt weiß man vielleicht ja da sind ja so kleine start trecker an bord die sagen ein wo guckt man satellit jetzt gerade hin.
Das hat jeder von den satelliten also die beobachten satelliten wo die ausrichtung des sagten wichtig ist äh an bord auch unser wetter satelliten damit man die vernünftig ausrichten kann haben.
Weil woran sollten sie sich sonst orientieren wenn ich an den sternen und die kennt man.
Ganz genau und diese stadtwerke die haben so einen kleinen stern katalog an bord die sagen irgendwelche richtung cookie guck ich gerade aber das mit ein paar boden sekunden genauigkeit also so fünfzehn bogen sekunden genauigkeit und mit gar ja wollen wir aber ja die mikro bogen sekunden erreichen.
Also braucht man erstmal eine referenz an der man das überhaupt ausrichten.
Das wäre schön wenn wir so eine referenz haar hätten haben wir aber nicht es gibt nichts was das so genau machen und wo ist jetzt der trick bei dem ganzen.
Wie man's vielleicht von dem gelesen zurück rechnet und sozusagen alles.
Ja so ein bisschen ja man müssen die geier daten selber benutzen um zu wissen wo der satellit hinguckt das heißt also wir starten sozusagen mit einem groben muster wo sind die sterne und.
Messen dann wo die sterne sind und wissen wir gucken wir.
Ja die sterne sind nicht ganz dahin wo unser sozusagen modell uns das sagt und aus der aus der differenz zwischen dem was wir vorher sagen wo der stern ist wo er dann wirklich gemessen wird.
Können wir dann auch am ende unter anderem herausbekommen wurde seit liegt grade hingucken das müssen wir mit der gleichen genauigkeit machen mit der wir die sterne position messen.
Weil sonst ist ja die auflösung wieder dahin.
Sonst ist die auflösung ich würd mich von auflösung sondern sozusagen richtig.
Die richtige genau die man die position wie kann man darf nicht also die die der scheibe was man von so einem stern hat dass es durchaus so groß dass es einige zehnte bogen sekunden ist aber die.
Da wo das zentrum des stern ist das was man zentrum das ist da wo der stern wirklich steht und das was
ja ja genau mist also deshalb darf man nicht von auf das auflösung gespielt natürlich eine große rolle also je größer der spiegel ist desto größer ist das auflösung vermögen aber es ist nicht so dass wir den die beiden objekte dann trennen könnten wenn sie so die genauigkeit von ga.
Äh voneinander entfernt hätten sondern wir können schon einen stern sagen der ist in der richtung mit der unter genauigkeit aber was jetzt noch wichtig.
Nicht nur die richtung des sterne es müssen also wo der said hingucken müssen wir kennen sondern wir müssen auch genau wissen wie es eigentlich unser teleskop welche welche eigenschaften hat das welche brennweite hat das genau oder.
Unsere cds die liegen ja irgendwo hundertsechzig cds die in unserer kamera ebene sind.
Und die sind mal von menschen da angebracht worden die könnten ja ja ein paar ganz klein bisschen verschoben sein gegenüber der position wo wir das ding gerne hätten.
Das heißt sie müssen auch erstmal.
Auch erstmal kalibriert und auch dazu benutzt man die daten selber das heißt also dass das ganze ist so dass wir außerdem.
Den beobachtungen die uns die sternen position am himmel geben der bewegung der sterne diese eigenen bewegung der stern am himmel und der paar lachse bewegung das ist das was wir eigentlich haben wollen von einem stern auch noch weitere.
Grüßen messen und das sind sozusagen nations parameter die uns sagen wo guckt man sattel die zu welchem zeitpunkt hin.
Wie sieht meine spiegel und meine äh das ganze sozusagen instrument kalibriert und wie ist meine pokale ebene kalibriert also diese geometrischen parameter.
Die selbst wenn man die von der erde genau gewusst hätte.
Dann hätte das wackeln beim staat in einer sojus rakete mit der das instrument gestartet wird auch alles wieder durcheinander gebracht das heißt und es verschiebt sich auch im laufe der zeit das bleibt nicht hundertprozentig konstant das heißt man muss solche variationen auch mit einrechnen.
Und ich vergleich das immer gerne damit münchen münchhausen der ja bekanntlich sich am eigenen shop aus dem sumpf gezogen hat,
so müssen die geier daten sozusagen selber dazu her gehen auch die die die dinge die man eigentlich als kapitulation als gerne externe daten hätten die sind dann auch gleichzeitig sozusagen helfen den satelliten zu kalibrieren und.
Ist das ist das dann so eine einzelne punkte methode dass man am laufenden meter sozusagen die position mist und daraus eine eigene position macht und daran wiederum das andere kalibriert was dann wieder die andere.
Ja das sehr gut super sehr gut eigentlich erklärt das ist so ähm wir haben also eine einem vorstellung in sein interaktiver prozess wie man das nennt äh.
Genau wir machen das schrittweise mathematisch gesehen das ist also mathematische verfahren wo man ein großes gleichung system von vielen millionen gleichung aufbaut um diese.
Parameter rauszubekommen und da gehen die gehen die zeitpunkte als größen ein wann ein stern über die pokal ebene wandert.
Und haben wir sozusagen an jetzt nehmen wir mal an wir wussten wir glauben zu wissen wo wo der wo der wo wir jetzt genau hingucken das nennt man die sterne es und welche geometrie wir haben
das das denken wir jetzt dass wir das zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt mit 'ner gewissen genauigkeit kennen und jetzt machen wir die eigentliche messung.
Und dann sehen wir dass unsere messung nicht wo modelliert nicht zu genau dem ergebnis führen was wir wirklich messen und da machen wir 'ne korrektur.
Für diese parameter ausrichtung geometrie des satelliten und die sternen position bewegung und parallel achsen.
Und im nächsten schritt haben wir eine bessere lösung und jetzt gucken wir wieder nach äh.
Passt das jetzt besser zu den einzelnen beobachtung staaten und wenn nicht dann werden diese sachen nochmal angepasst und irgendwann das haben wir übrigens vom staat schon beweisen.
Werden nur parameter angepasst oder wird auch das mathematische.
Es wird auch das mathematische modell angepasst das nennt man da die eigentliche qualifikation wo man viele viele daten hineinstecken muss um
um wirklich die dinge noch zu verstehen das führt auch dann nachher dazu führt dass dann auch systematisch für fehler drin sind um das ganze zu machen also die eigentliche kleinarbeit.
Bei der astronomie try die liegt darin den satelliten richtig zu verstehen richtig zu modellieren und
dann dieses gleichung system zu gewissen also diese schritte müssen eben mit dieser hohen genauigkeit gemacht werden und und und das klappt schon sehr sehr gut aber wir sind natürlich anspruchsvoll und wollen das am ende natürlich bis zum
bis zu der genauigkeit bringen die wir mal ursprünglich vorhaben dass wir also sowohl die zufälligen fehler als auch die systematische fehler
sehr sehr klein bekommen und da steckt eine menge menge arbeit drin und da darf kommt man auch immer mal auf die falschen ideen woran es denn liegt das jetzt irgendwie abweichung ist die man noch nicht versteht.
Und wir müssen ein paar schlaue leute sich zusammensetzen um dann
herauszubekommen wie das ist und dann stellt man fest dass nicht jetzt doch nicht daran woran man das gedacht hätte sondern hat 'ne andere idee so wird das ganze system im laufe der zeit verbessert und aber wir haben schon sehr wir haben natürlich möglichkeiten die interne genauigkeit auch schon zu testen wie gut die eigentlich ist also wir
wir sind ja nicht völlig blind was das angeht sondern wir versuchen aber sozusagen immer wieder die qualifikation ist satelliten zu verbessern und das ist 'ne wahnsinnige aufgabe die auch,
'ne manpower erfordert und vor allen dingen viele schlaue köpfe die sich darüber gedanken machen wie das geht und dann braucht man eben auch computer die das ganze analysieren.
Wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen dass sozusagen die messe genauigkeit auch äh quasi impliziert diesen mess fehler auch mit
bringt wenn jetzt quasi alles sich gegenseitig also wenn das wenn sozusagen die raumsonde sich am universum und das universum an der raumsonde kalibriert und man das sozusagen über diesen interaktiven prozess auf eine immer höhere genauigkeit äh bringt und dabei im versucht auch diesen fehler zu reduzieren
wir haben vorhin so gesprochen mit na ja dann können wir das auch sonst wie boden sekunden runterbrechen das hier sozusagen jetzt die eine perspektive wenn man das jetzt mal umdreht,
welche genauigkeit der genauen position der raum sondern also kann man den mess fehler der position der raum sondern irgendwie so in zentimetern oder ein metern oder kilometern ausdrücken.
Ja genau wir brauchen auch die die position der raumsonde sehr genau das ist eine etwas versichert übrigens gar nicht erwähnt hatte bei der ganzen geschichte.
Genau weil das auch natürlich wir müssen den beobachtungen standort kennen und der ist ja nicht die erde wie bei der normalen parallel messung vom erdboden außerdem bei galeria und geier steht übrigens nicht genau in diesem l zwei sondern macht ein orbit um diese lagerung punkt herum.
So eine so eine ja so 'ne liste figur nennt man das und die die in allen raum richtung schwingt das ding in einem halben jahr von einer seite auf die andere
und das ist durchaus riesen großer bereich dreihundertfünfzigtausend kilometer amplitude hat das ding das ist also wir vermeiden ja sogar dass wir in den zwei ganz genau gehen das,
da komme ich gleich noch drauf aber um jetzt erst mal diesen gedanken zu ende zu machen um jetzt die parallel eine sterns zu messen
keine super hohe genauigkeit weil die sterne einfach weit weg sind oder wie ein kleiner fehler von ein paar hundert kilometern oder so kein großes problem aber ähm weil wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel die
objekt in unserem sonnensystem auch gut beobachten wollen zum beispiel astrid die sind ja so nah dass dann natürlich wenn wir die verhandlungsposition nicht genau haben.
Ja mal wieder die strommast.
Genau da haben wir wieder den strom maskeneffekt und äh dann äh dann können wir die nicht genau da müssen wir hundertfünfzig meter genau wissen wo gar ja ist zu jedem zeitpunkt
und es gibt noch was anderes was was was uns das ganze schwierig macht nicht nur die position sondern auch die geschwindigkeit des satelliten ich sprach ja von diesem.
Doppelter effekt ins einmal gibt aber wenn sich ein objekt bewegt im universum.
Verkürzt ist natürlich auch.
Sterne auch das nennt man operation des lichtes und die werden wir jetzt mal nur die erde nehmen wenn wir von der erde aus ein sterben beobachten.
Dann ist es ja so dass das licht mit dreißigtausend dreihunderttausend kilometer pro sekunde durchs universum pflicht aber unsere erde mit dreißig kilometer pro sekunde pflicht.
Das heißt also unsere erde hat ein zehntausendsten.
Der geschwindigkeit des lichtes mit der die erde sich um die um die sonne bewegt und das führt dazu dass die das licht nicht aus der richtung genau kommt.
Aus der es zu kommen äh ja aus scheint von der von der beobachtung her sondern um einen kleinen winkel verschoben sind das sind zwanzig bis zu zwanzig oder einen fast einundzwanzig bogen sekunden.
Wir reden davon jetzt millionsten ellbogen sekunden zu messen das heißt diesen effekt müssen wir sehr genau kennen das heißt.
Könnt ihr jetzt gar ja da gar ja 'ne andere geschwindigkeit hat müssen wir die geschwindigkeit von gary auf ein paar millimeter pro sekunde genau kennen und das
dazu brauchen wir wenn wir nachher den endgültigen stern katalog herstellen möglichst genau den orbit und dazu machen wir
macht eins der programme die von gallia gemacht werden ist die geier von der erde aus zu beobachten und darum mit die bahn transfer saal der richtung zum zum beispiel zu bestimmen.
Und zusätzlich zum paar messungen die man mit radio antenne machen kann da kann man die entfernung sehr gut messen.
Und man kann mit mehreren tanten auch gar ja anpeilen dann hätte man auch sehr genaue raum lage aber das ist sehr teuer dazu brauchen immer zwei antennen und deshalb.
Gerne von der erde dass man das genauer bestimmen kann und für ein großteil der mission müssen wir den orbit sehr sehr genau kennen äh teilweise können wir auch ein paar informationen aus dem geier daten selber wieder über den orbit ermitteln das wären dann weitere parameter aber wir brauchen.
Diese diese extra messe rundet die die man mit hilfe von.
Echt täglichen oder alle paar täglichen besserung zum beispiel von jesu in chile wert wird gar ja dann analysiert und gemessen und.
Nehmen ab ob die schon einfach fotografiert man fotografiert die region mal guckt sich sogar ja es ist einer der punkte da sterben nur ein stern dass ich relativ schnell bewegt weil da ja sicher natürlich im laufe der zeit bewegt
aber relativ zum paar sterne in der umgebung kann man dann messen wo gar ja sich befindet.
Also die helligkeit des kommt durch die reflexion auf den solar parallel die natürlich da genau auch in richtung erde sind weil es ja hinter der erde.
Genau ja ja würde sich selber übrigens gar nicht oder kaum sehen könnt der geier hat nämlich eine ähm.
Helligkeit die so ungefähr einundzwanzigste größe oder zweiundzwanzigste grüße von der erde aussieht also es wäre grade an der messe genauigkeit von dem was geil ja selber hätte
es ist ein relativ schwaches objekt aber mit dem mit dem teleskop so von der zwei meter größe
bei einer europäischen süd sternwarte und auch einigen anderen teleskopen sich an dieser messe kampagne beteiligen kann man diese diese sachen machen und das ist alles liegt daran dass wir so hoch genau arbeiten dass wir all diese effekte mit einbeziehen müssen.
Diese cds sind aber nicht das einzige instrument.
An bord das ist oder oder wird damit alles gemacht weil es ist ja jetzt nicht nur die beobachtung des lichts san.
Richtig verstanden habe ist ja gar ja auch in der lage spektral analyse des lichtes zu machen also nicht
nur licht in seiner intensität festzustellen sondern eben auch noch die darin enthalten frequenzen zu interpretieren
zumindest für sterne die jetzt nicht so weit der eine bestimmte mindest helligkeit haben eben mit dem ziel nicht nur zu wissen wo bist du wie schnell bist du groß bist der etcetera sondern eben auch.
Woraus
besteht denn das ganze weil spektrums kopie heißt ja im prinzip schauen was äh quasi in dem licht absolviert wird und dann aussagen der uhr zu treffen wie viel wasserstoff sauerstoff etcetera
ist äh dort fahren ist dasselbe instrument oder.
Ja die.
Spielen bei all diesen beobachtungen rolle aber ähm sie haben in der tat recht dass das oder du hast recht ist dass es ganz wesentlichen dass wir nicht nur eine messung machen über die astronomie stern ist wenn wir nichts über den stern sonst wissen es ist eigentlich ziemlich sinnlose aussage ich meine
wir wollen ja die sterne verstehen deshalb muss man irgendwie andere daten mit diesem entfernung s und bewegungsmuster natürlich irgendwie in zusammenhang bringen deshalb ist das enorm wichtig dass wir doch was anderes messen und zwar äh messen wir ähm
kleine spektren wo also die das licht in die einzelnen wellenlänge auf gespaltet werden das heißt vor einigen dieser cds die wir haben haben wir auch äh
die dafür sorgen dass das licht in einzelne wellenlänge auf gespaltet wird und zwar gibt es da ein ein messer instrument welches.
Die wellenlänge im,
kurzweiligen bereich im blauen bereich wie man sagt vermisst und eins instrument was es im roten bereich vermisst nicht mit sehr hohe auflösung aber damit bekommen wir ungefähr heraus.
Was für ein spektral typ das ist ob das 'n stern ist der zum beispiel sehr heiß ist dann sind sterne sehr blau
haben also mehr in diesen blauen foto meter wie wir das ganze nennen oder ähm wenn ein stern kühl ist dann ist es sicher dann äh hätte mehr fluss in dem in dem rötlichen foto meter was wir an bord haben aber die fotos werden nachher tatsächlich
wieder detektiert mit hilfe der cd detektor aber davor sind denn geräte trifft man in dem fall die das licht in die einzelne wellenlänge zerlegen
und dann haben wir noch ein.
Nämlich nicht viel licht raus also.
Die in der tat ist es so dass wir da natürlich dadurch dass es in die einzelnen wellenlänge.
Wird das licht natürlich pro pixel weniger ähm fluss haben als bei beide astronom betrieb wo wir ja so alles sozusagen auf einen punkt.
Oder einen kleinen bereich äh fokussieren können ist das in der tat so dass wir das natürlich dann äh weniger signal bekommen aber da wir ein stern immer mal wieder beobachten können wir das auch am ende auf so mir das was wir für den stern beobachten.
In einigen fällen bei den helleren würde man sogar variation des spektrums was es auch bei stern gibt es gibt ja veränderlich stern natürlich dann auch äh entsprechend analysieren.
Sind diese prisma optional und werden irgendwie reingefahren oder luft das licht generell auch immer durch die presse und die immer alles spektral aufgeteilt auf.
Die nehmen das ist das letzte ist der fall das heißt jeder sterben dadurch unsere pokal ebene läuft läuft erstmal an
neun streifen von cds vorbei wo diese astro methodischen messung gemacht werden übrigens da heißt astro mitreden natürlich auch 'ne helligkeit messung die können wir immer sozusagen mit messen die gesamt helligkeit.
Die ein solches instrument misst aber dann gibt es noch so zwei streifen wo ein stern auch drüber geht und dass er immer auch von
diese spektren erzeugt werden das wird für jeden sternen gemacht aber mit um die relativ niedrige auflösung es gibt
noch weitere ein instrument welches noch weitere spektren macht dass es im nahen infrarot bereich wo man nur ein kleinen spektral bereich hat.
Und wo man dann sehr viel höher die wellenlänge auflöst um damit dann in doppelter effekt zu messen das ist tatsächlich
nicht alle sterne immer mitbekommen weil das nur
weil die sterne die zum beispiel zu tief in durch unser pokal ebene laufen laufen an diesem instrument vorbei und dadurch dass dann die abspaltung auch äh sehr viel.
Größer ist äh kriegen wir noch weniger proton sodass wir das nur für die allerletzten sterne machen können vielleicht am ende einige zieht bis eine vielleicht hundert millionen sterne im gegensatz zu den milliarden sternen die wir.
Sonst haben aber.
Bei gaia in unserem zweiten stern katalog haben wir für eins komma mehr als eins komma drei milliarden sterne auch die helligkeit im blauen im roten bereich zu mess gemessen von unserem zweiten katalog haben wir nämlich
diese spektren die wir eigentlich messen ähm noch nicht als wirkliche spektren analysiert
dafür ist einfach nicht genügend zeit gewesen und auch die qualifikation muss noch ein bisschen verbessert werden da haben wir einfach sozusagen einfach.
Proton zusammengezählt die in dem blauen spektrum meter und den roten spektrum meter sind sodass wir wissen wie hell ist der stern.
Bei kurzen wählen den wie heißt er stand bei den
den längeren wellenlänge und aus der differenz dieser beiden kann man das dann über die farbe des sterns sagen da kann man also sagen ob es stern blau oder rot ist heiß oder kühl ist zum beispiel das ist eine sache aus dem anderen instrument was ich sagte was hochauflösend da kann man dann tatsächlich sogar
bei einigen stern auch aussagen zum beispiel die chemische zusammensetzung führen weil der spektral linien sind die ganz bestimmten elementen zugeordnet sind sodass man auch dann
weitere informationen über den stern bekommt es ist aber nicht immer nötig von geier aus alle messung zu machen
sondern man hat natürlich auch äh vom kampf manche sachen vom erdboden auch aus sehr gut machen solche spektren aufzunehmen hat dann aber die genauen geier daten
und kann das dann miteinander kombinieren das heißt also am ende wenn mich wissenschaft betreiben dann nehme ich nie nur ein katalog auch wenn der geier katalog fantastisch ist wenn ich andere daten zur verfügung habe dann sollte ich die auch benutzen so dass halt am ende
die kombination von vielen daten aus vielen äh durch musterung des himmels oder einzelne messung des himmels am ende die wissenschaft macht aber die geier daten werden immer eine ganz ganz große rolle bei dieser,
diesen zusammenfügen aus verschiedenen wählen den bereichen spielen.
Ich glaub zum verständnis der art und weise wie diese unterschiedliche
gleichzeitig oder nacheinander zur anwendung kommen müssen wir glaube ich noch mal in detail aufgreifen es wird euch so noch nicht erwähnt haben aber sich jetzt noch aus der letzten sendung erinnere geier ist ja jetzt nicht so.
Das ist einfach nur an eine stelle guckt und
wartet was passiert deswegen rotiert die ganze zeit und es im prinzip wie so ein scanner der äh die ganze zeit immer so so ein streifen beobachtet das heißt diese langsame rotation die ja auch zur eigenen stabilisierung des geräts dient nämlich zumindest mal an das
macht irgendwas muss ich ja immer drin und äh auf jeden fall
ist das sozusagen so ein fortlaufend des rundum drehen wie so 'n wie so 'n leuchtturm sozusagen nur andersrum wird es halt immer alles scheibchenweise gemacht und in dieser rotation.
Wir werden dann sozusagen auch all diese ganzen instrumente nacheinander bedient das heißt man schaut halt sich erstmal das eine das andere was andere an und die sind alle so ein bisschen so nebeneinander und warten darauf dass sie irgendwie versorgt werden.
Ganz genau also das ist das was du das
tasten des himmels oder das steckt dahinter also dieses gesetz also ihr habt eine ganz bestimmte strategie den himmel ab zu tasten also angenommen sie wollen dreihundertsechzig grad bild machen von ihrer umgebung dann ist alles was um sie herum ist äh muss dann gemessen werden sie haben 'ne kamera die nur in eine richtung guckt jetzt
dann können sie zum beispiel die kamera nehmen und dann horizontal erstmal alles.
Panorama.
Genauso aber da fehlt das was oben und unten ist das heißt man muss ein bisschen dadrüber was machen und da drunter machen und da hat man ein bestimmtes ab das gesetz wo im laufe der zeit
der gesamte himmel abgetastet wird und das wichtige ist auch aus ganz verschiedenen richtungen das heißt also wir wollen nicht immer nur sagen wir mal
äh horizontal sag erstmal horizontal obwohl es das ja in dem sinne nicht gibt
essen sondern auch mal von oben nach unten oder quer dazu je mehr daten aus den verschiedenen richtungen nachher hattest du genauer kann man nachher den die sachen zusammenfügen und daher hat er äh eine strategie das ist erstmal das erstmal
alle sechs stunden einmal um die eigene achse sich dreht
und in diesen sechs stunden das heißt vier mal am tag rotiert gaia und gleichzeitig ist es so dass gaia immer alles achse immer fünfundvierzig grad relativ zur sonne
guckt das heißt also dieser winkel muss auch aus technischen gründen immer ganz genau stabil eingehalten werden und.
Damit haben wir schonmal zwei bewegung die gala macht die rotation und diese fünfundvierzig grad
denn die sonne läuft ja scheinbar einmal im jahr um gar ja herum und wirklichkeit läuft ja gar ja natürlich genau mit der erde auch um die sonne vor diesem punkt läuft sie rum.
Und jetzt gibt's noch 'ne dritte bewegung.
Wenn wenn wir diese richtung zur sonne um fünfundvierzig grad beibehalten dann können wir im prinzip diese zur richtung von der sonne noch einmal so um die sonne herum kreisen sozusagen mit der axel
kann man es verstehen warum also angenommen die achse zeigt fünfundvierzig grad oberhalb dieser der sonne richtung.
Dann könnte es ja genauso gut unterhalb oder links oder rechts stehen geblieben fünfundvierzig grad das heißt einmal in dreiundsechzig tagen dreht sich die
um die sonne herum damit hat man drei bewegung die dann dazu führen dass im laufe der zeit der gesamte himmel abgetastet wird nach ungefähr.
Glaube so ungefähr hundertfünfzig hundertsechzig tagen hat man ungefähr jeden teil des himmels auf diese weise dann einmal.
Mindestens einmal.
Mein wenn manche teile schon mehrmals und im laufe der zeit dann äh wird das so gemacht dass man dann viele beobachtung aus verschiedenen richtungen hat
und äh das ist das was wir als abtasten gesetzt haben und dann laufen eben dadurch dass geier sicher dreht
laufen dann die sterne scheinbar durch die pokal ebene und werden dann von den einzelnen instrumenten wie du richtig sagt es aufgenommen zunächst einmal gibt's dann streifen das guckt erstmal ist da überhaupt einen stern.
Das ist der sogenannte das ist der der das sagt uns da ist da überhaupt einen stern denn
wir können gar nicht alle unsere daten von den cds zur erde funken sondern wir wir.
Wir können nur so kleine fenster um den stern herum zu erde funken denn sonst würden unsere acht megabit niemals ausreichen um mit
den kontakt den wir für sechs bis acht stunden typischerweise am tag zur boden station haben das rüber zu.
Und auch der deutsche ist ja darauf optimiert dass man sozusagen nur speichert was man auch wirklich speichern muss alles nichts muss nicht gespeichert werden.
Genau also die bereiche sozusagen sind brauchen es wäre schön wenn wir vielleicht den gesamten himmel im hätten gibt dann würde man vielleicht noch mehr aufnehmen aber es ist schon sehr optimiert dann wird man mit dieser datenübertragung rate am ende das
optimum hat und es läuft ein stern nachdem wir dann detektiert ist werden dann so kleine fenster ausgeschnitten die dann auch über
mit der rate mit der die sterne dann darüber das c laufen das dauert immer so vier komma eins sekunden für prozess idee so lange braucht ein stern übung darüber zu laufen
mit genau dieser geschwindigkeit ausgelesen und dann gibt es neun solche streifen von cds wo ein stern drüber weg läuft wo dann dessen,
position gemessen wird also neun von diesem feldern sind dazu da dann kommen zwei streifen die das.
Blaue das rote foto meter umfassen wovor wie ich eben sagte er ein prisma ist wo dann sozusagen nicht nur sterne sind sondern so kleine spektren darüber laufen mit dieser geschwindigkeit und dann gibt es noch das so ein drittes feld wo cd sind.
Wo dann diese äh hochauflösend spektren gemacht werden an infrarot um die doppelter effekt die geschwindigkeit der sterne auf uns zu davon uns weg gemessen werden das heißt also sozusagen das ist wirklich wie du sagtest.
So ähm jedes instrument bekommt sozusagen kleinen zeit scheibe für die entsprechenden messung während der stern dann über die pokale ebene.
Wenn jetzt sozusagen durch diese mehrfach bewegung also das ding hat diese figur für wird mit der erde mitgeführt rotiert.
Und alles wird mindestens einmal angeguckt werden zeitraum von.
Sag mal jetzt mal das läuft zehn jahre was es so die mindest anzahl von beobachtung momenten für die sterne die am wenigsten beobachtet werden also was sozusagen.
Zehnmal hundertmal.
Also innerhalb von fünf jahren ähm das ist ja unsere reguläre messe seid ihr jetzt im juli
ähm da ist es so dass zwischen dreißig und etwa zweihundertfünfzig mal jeder stern ein transit durch unsere pokal ebene macht.
Während jedes transit läuft es ja denn neun mal über cds um messung zu machen das heißt wir haben ungefähr wenn wir jetzt mal nicht neun sondern zehn
messung das heißt wir haben also mindestens dreihundert messung pro sternen für am für die sterne die am wenigsten gemessen werden.
Aus wieviel unterschiedlichen position ist wird ein stern mindestens.
Genau das sind das sind die das sind die dreißig ungefähr positionen die.
Und maximal.
Zweihundertfünfzig mal und und ähm das hängt 'n bisschen von der region am himmel ab das sterne zum beispiel der clip
da wo die planeten sich bewegen die wird am wenigsten abgetastet ist auch aus verschiedenen gründen zum beispiel die parallel messung da nicht so so entscheidend an der stelle aber die ähm es ist so dass die
die messung also ein bisschen über den himmel variieren aber in den zehn jahren bekommen natürlich denn die doppelte anzahl messe von messung und diese das dann die am ende
die verschiedenen parameter in diesem großen gleichung system von indem ich da geredet habe dann nachher äh sagt wie schnell bewegt sich der stern welche entfernung hat er und welche.
Position am himmel.
Ja und vor allem umso länger das ganze läuft umso mehr entdeckt man ja auch extrem langsame bewegung.
Richtig genau also das das heißt also.
Ja auch sein dass eine direkt auf und zu sich bewegt und man das irgendwie gar nicht so wahrnimmt vor.
Ja aber das mit den auch von zugeben dass wir ja der doppel
können wir am schlechtesten eigentlich messen auch wenn da können boden gebundene instrumente sogar die messung besser machen aber der grund warum wann geier sozusagen dieses instrument noch dabei ist einfach damit wir für möglichst viele sterne
auch diese dritte information dabei haben es ist ja so was haben wir nachher physikalisch astro physikalisch an informationen ähm wir haben.
Drei.
Die position im raum wir wissen ja die richtung und wir wissen die entfernung damit haben wir also sagen alle drei raum richtung eines sterne es mit einem gewissen west fehler natürlich immer im raum und dann haben wir zwei geschwindigkeit komponenten nämlich wieder stern sich an der himmels faire bewegt und dann haben wir noch die dritte komponente ob der sterben sich auf uns zu der von uns
bewegt das ist
das werden wir am ende nur für vielleicht hundert millionen sterne oder so haben diese dritte komponente aber dann haben wir sozusagen auch die geschwindigkeit in allen drei raum richtung und das ist natürlich für das was dich der lateinamerika die sich mit der bewegung der sterne in unserer galaxis beschäftigen genau das was sie haben wollen
im zweiten stern katalog der am fünfundzwanzigsten april letzten jahres veröffentlicht wurde da ist es so dass wir nur für sieben millionen sterne bisher diese dritte komponente auch haben ist immerhin
ist das die doppelte anzahl von messung in der radikalen bewegung die man vorher hatte aber das das
das ist der wertvollste daten satz eigentlich da wo man alle informationen zusammen hat.
Für den rest der sterne fehlt eine der dimension die man dann äh gerne hätte aber die dann einfach nicht möglich ist dass nicht nur mich daran dass wenn man hochauflösend spektren hat
wird das licht ja in die einzelnen sozusagen pixel verteilt und damit hat man nicht
genügend signal beides stern zum beispiel zwanzig komma siebter größe diese dreißigtausend kilometer entfernung kerze sondern dass da muss man ungefähr dann sagen wir mal.
Ja mehr sterne nimm die die deutlich heller sind die die da bist bist du der für die man da noch die diese dritte messung auch machen kann.
Bevor wir zum finale und der ganzen auswertung dieser jetzt von diesem instrumenten gemacht
nochmal ganz kurz auf den ablauf der mission selber nochmal kommen wie schon erwähnt der letzte podcast.
Wurde ja ein tag vor dem staat veröffentlicht da muss man noch nicht.
Ja hat mir natürlich alle angst die wir daran.
Muss doch der schlimmste tag sein oder ist man da nicht völlig.
Ja das ist das schlimmste und gleichzeitig natürlich ein schöner tag wenn man sieht es sieht so aus als ob alles funktioniert oder zumindest das wichtigste funktioniert.
Aber so tag davor.
Ja das man ist nervös ganz klar also das ist es ist äh etwas woran man so lange wo das herz auch natürlich dran.
Ich bin ja mein arbeitet er zehn jahre dran man hat sich 'n kopf gemacht und gedanken gemacht man weiß auch wenn wenn das ding ist einfach verblüht dann.
Hat man auch in seinem eigenen leben vielleicht unter umständen gar nicht mehr die gelegenheit das nochmal wiederholen weil selbst wenn irgendjemand sagen würde auch scheiß drauf legen wir die ganze kohle nochmal hinbauen normal.
Dauert es ist viele dinge werden dann wieder anders und.
Richtig nein das ist 'n ganz ganz.
Ja in gewisser weise schlimmer und am ende wenn es dann klappt schöner moment dass man dann sieht also als wir dann gesehen haben das sonnen fehlen diese große schirm von zehn einhalb metern geöffnet
die instrumente von der sonne abgeschirmt und wo unten dann auch die solarzellen dran sind das ist ungefähr anderthalb stunden nach dem start passiert äh
da haben wir dann zum ersten mal auch mit sekt angestoßen dass alles gut gewesen.
Ja nicht dass das nicht noch dinge schief gehen können und es gab auch probleme weil es beginnt ja dann äh klassische ablauf bei den raumfahrt missionen man hat den staat das macht dann halt die in dem fall halt die russen
den balkon ne.
Nein das war das war in französisch guyana in der nähe von.
Die europäische seriös.
Ja ja genau die die die es dort gestartet und und die kontrolle wurde er zum beispiel darmstadt gemacht.
Aber die ariane gruppe macht halt den den staat vor ort und dann äh übernehmen halt genau die in darmstadt wo wir schon sehr oft waren und auch das erste gespräch war ja
florian der dort mission analyst ist und genau diese phase dann eben übernimmt das heißt kaum ist sozusagen der
geführt und die piloten freigesetzt dann geht es eben darum die dinge.
Hinkommt wie lange dauerte die reise dann bis an den l zwei.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere na musst du so vierzehn tage ungefähr gewesen sein der flug dorthin.
Und ja dann sind wir dort gewesen und dann auch zum ersten mal die ersten messung gemacht und.
Am ende haben wir dann in relativ kurzer zeit auch 'n großen schreck bekommen also weil eben doch nicht so alles so gut funktioniert und eines der dinge die wir da gesehen haben ist.
Das eins der beiden teleskope innerhalb von einundzwanzig tagen nur noch ein drittel so der empfindlichkeit hatte und wenn man.
Dann fünf jahre beobachten will dann kann man sagen das instrument wäre wenn man das einfach so extra poliert innerhalb von wenigen wochen eigentlich tot gewesen und.
Man braucht ja auch beide.
Genau man braucht beide und ist das bei der instrumente haben auch ähm haben wir auch äh sozusagen signal verloren eins noch mehr als das andere und dann war erstmal die frage wo nichts denn jetzt und man kam sehr schnell darauf dass es wahrscheinlich daran liegt dass da wasser an.
Von wo aus wurde den sozusagen die übernahme gemacht also die darmstadt kümmert sich ja nach wie vor sozusagen.
Ja
Flugbetrieb aber wann übernimmt man sozusagen das instrumentarium.
Ja das das das geht erst nach also die sogenannte über übernahme die ist erst nachdem was man komische ding denn das ist über ein halbes jahr gewesen wo.
Da ja dann auf herz und nieren geprüft wurde übrigens auch mit großer beteiligung von äh der universität heidelberg die ein ganz wesentlicher teil macht nämlich die sogenannten first look das ist sozusagen die tägliche qualitätskontrolle der geier daten wo wir
computer programme sind die äh täglich prüfen ob alles in ordnung ist welche messe messung man hat welche
genauigkeit man hat man hat sogar so eine sogenannte astronomische lösung die man tage weise macht und da kann man dann gucken
sieht das eigentlich gut aus und da haben wir ein computerprogramm und natürlich leute die dann auf die daten drauf
gucken wo täglich diese qualitätskontrolle gemacht wird und das ist auch eine der wesentlichen beiträge der universität heidelberg die da 'ne rolle.
Rolle spielen und zusammen mit mit äh kollegen äh aus anderen instituten haben wir dann gesehen dass.
Eben die sterne immer schwächer zu werden schienen äh auf den instrumenten und äh die was relativ schnell klar wurde war dass es sich wahrscheinlich um wasser antwort handelt was
auf dem kalten instrumenten die ja ungefähr minus hundert grad celsius haben sich dann äh in form von eis abgesetzt haben und das passiert
bei jedem satelliten eigentlich dass der wasser antwortest aber wir haben schon zu dem während des fluges zum l zwei die gar ja ein bisschen aufgeheizt damit
genauso was er dampf was da noch drin ist äh heraus der fundiert und äh herausbekommt oder sollte eigentlich nichts mehr drin sein das war auch das was von der konstruktion her angenommen war.
Aber dann fehlt stellt man fest es muss doch was drin sein und das setzt sich dann ab und na ja was wir gemacht haben ist man hat.
Die heizen elemente angeworfen und hat dann gesehen es geht weg das also schon mal ein guter beweis dafür dass es sich darum gehandelt hat aber ähm
ja es kam dann eben nach einigen monaten auch immer wieder das hat so ziemlich großer nervosität geführt und.
Also man weiß ich aber eine schon sicher dass das wasser ist war's auch wasser.
Na ja so könnte man sagen ok dann machen wir alle woche schnell mal die elemente an aber die bringen natürlich unsere instrument dadurch dass dann thermisch
sich wieder alles verändert die temperatur spannend
und wir wollen ja grade mit der hohen genauigkeit messen wo wir das ding teppich und nicht stabil halten das ging nicht braucht ungefähr gar ja braucht wenn es denn solche aufhalten hat ungefähr wieder so drei wochen bis die
so funktionieren wie sie eigentlich funktionieren sollen.
Der verbraucher die ganze zeit treibstoff und verkürzt die mission.
Ja auf jeden fall zeitliche lücken hat man in den guten daten und solche lücken existieren natürlich aufgrund der tatsache dass man solche
aufhalten hatte auch immer wieder das heißt wir haben trotzdem regelmäßig alle paar monate dann aufheizen müssen und haben dadurch immer wieder garten daten verloren und.
Das gute ist das jetzt inzwischen das wasser vollständig wächst sein scheint also da ist jetzt seitdem wir das letzte mal.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wann es war auf ungefähr vor ich sag jetzt mal etwas mehr als einem halben jahr oder dreiviertel jahr kann es jetzt auch hier sein ich hab das nicht mehr so im kopf.
Seit dem letzten aufheizen hat sich da nichts mehr getan und wir sind jetzt da stabil das ist also eine sehr sehr gute sache ähm dass also.
Diese dieses problem wirklich beseitigt ist also eins von den problemen die man so hat mir zum satelliten ja woher das wasser kommt wissen wir übrigens überhaupt nicht so richtig denn in dem instrumenten teil da war eigentlich ganz klar gesagt da darf
das darf nur so viel wasser sein wie man durch
dieses aufheizen während des fluges zum lehrgang punkt l zwei auch weggeht aber da muss irgend 'ne quelle sein die die man nicht kennt von von und
die aber zum glück jetzt vorsicht also dieses problem haben wir nicht.
Ok ich meine man muss ja auch klar machen wenn man da jetzt eis auf den auf den augen hat und man heißt es weg kleiner wird das zu wasserdampf aber da ist ja kein wind.
Nee das ist richtig aber man hat vakuum vakuum und irgendwann haben die eine chance die kühle dann raus zu fliegen.
Ja was nicht so dass sie gleich fliegen sondern wir müssen halt so weg treiben so langsam weg kritisieren.
Heimat ist sie auch nicht vorstellen dass das aufheizen jetzt irgendwie auf hundert grad aufheizen heißt sondern auf minus fünfzig grad also das ist sehr moderat was man da macht.
Aber das hilft schon um das wegzukriegen das haben wir immer gesehen aber na ja ja genau genau na ja und es ist ebenso.
Was immer man an mühe sich macht umso tabletten am ende perfekt funktionieren zu lassen man wann es werden immer kleine dinge passieren die von dem abweichen was man vorher hatte
und das wichtige ist dass das keine was man so fühlen auf norddeutsch show stopper nennt äh hat die an die ganze mission versauen also das sind schon dinge die ärgerlich sind und
schön wäre wenn wenn wenn diese probleme nicht da wären da gibt's noch ein paar kleine andere dinge die da eine rolle spielen also zum beispiel haben wir neulich war's ein bisschen stärker ist als wir es ursprünglich mal haben wollten
das liegt unter anderem daran dass da so kleine.
Fasern wahrscheinlich nicht so perfekt abgeschnitten sind an dem schirm die dazu führen dass da so ein bisschen mehr streuung licht äh
an dem sonnenschirm der das eigentlich ablehnten soll dass dadurch licht ein bisschen mehr reinkommt
das gibt ein bisschen mehr hintergrund das heißt bei den schwachen sternen macht das die beobachtung etwas schlechter.
Ungefähr dreißig prozent der genauigkeit verlieren wir dann an den ganz schwachen ende aber das ist etwas womit wir leben können und bei der verlängerten des jungen gleich mit dass auch locker wieder aus also dadurch haben wir also.
Probleme die auch die qualifikation in gewisser weise schwieriger macht aber die am ende zu machen sind aber.
Dann gibt es noch eine sache die sehr ärgerlich ist ich sagte ja das beste wäre wenn der winkel von hundertsechs komma fünf grad zwischen diesen beiden.
Gesichts feldern absolut konstant bleibt und wir sehen aber dass deine schwankungen ist.
Und die ist deutlich höher als die die wir eigentlich haben wollten und äh.
Wie macht einiges an problemen bei der auswertung das muss man alles heraus.
Das schwanken ist das nicht fest verbaut.
Das ist äh ja aber es ist meine abstand zur sonne zum beispiel ändert sich ja im laufe eines jahres die erde hat ja auch 'n abstand der variiert im januar
um den fünften januar herum haben wir die dichtesten ernährung an die sonne und da kriegen wir.
Etwas mehr sonnenstrahlung als wenn wir im juli sind.
Also ich mache auf der erde macht das ja keinen großen unterschied ist ja eher die.
Genau aber trotzdem die strahlung ist leicht unterschiedliche bei so einem hochpräzise instrumente figuya spielt das 'ne rolle ob ihr ein bisschen näher an der sonne kriegen denn mit dem quadrat des abstand des variiert ja die einen strahlung.
Das heißt wir haben etwas verschiedene temperatur nur ist eigentlich gar ja so so konstruiert dass die instrumente weil wenn sich das hat ein bisschen ausdehnt oder wieder zusammenzieht was er ja ganz ganz leicht
in bei jeder art von temperaturen variation machen muss physikalisch dass das möglichst entkoppelt ist und diese entkoppelung funktioniert vielleicht nicht so perfekt
wie man sagt es gibt noch kein so ganz klare modell warum diese schwankungen da wirklich ist auf jeden fall sie deutlich größer als wir sie haben wollen und.
Und da sitzt die mathematiker werden sagen ok nochmal eine variable rein.
Da müssen wir noch eine variable reinpacken ja zum glück haben wir ein instrument an bord was diesen winkel mist dass es ähm.
Das ist der sogenannte basic engel monitor der basis winkel monitor den wir da drin haben der misst das mit hilfe eines etablierung meters übrigens also insofern.
Ein kleines interview meter an wort aber äh ähm das nicht zur messung der stern position benutzt wird aber.
Aber diese winkel sehr gut.
Sehr gut messen ganz genau deshalb hat man dieses messer instrument an bord und damit können wir ziemlich gut sagen wie groß das ist aber der punkt ist nun so 'n besser die kann man immer nur an zwei.
Im system machen oder wird zumindest bei diesem instrument gemacht aber das kann ja durchaus über das gesicht fällt ein bisschen unterschiedlich sein das heißt das sind noch weitere parameter wenn wir für den bisherigen katalog haben wir einfach angenommen dass.
Dieses messer instrument genau die variation liefert die auch in der realität stattfindet.
Für die zukünftigen kataloge wollen wir dann auch gucken ob wir das noch ein bisschen besser aufgrund der geier daten selber bekommen und mit hilfe von verschiedenen
weiteren ideen die man hat um das auszugleichen also auf jeden fall kompliziert dass die auswertung der geier daten enorm und.
Also was wir uns eingekauft haben ist durch diese kleinen probleme es ist alles viel schwieriger als wär 's ohnehin gedacht haben,
ähm das gute ist geier funktioniert eigentlich ganz hervorragend trotz dieser probleme und ähm ja.
Wir haben ein instrument was hervorragend funktioniert aber
es sind immer unikate die werden da hoch schickt und man kann ja nicht einfach eine reparatur mission die man da wo man mal schnell was ende hat und
man wüsste gar nicht so ganz genau was man da jetzt ändert man müsste bei zukünftigen
instrument natürlich gucken wie kann man solche fehler vermeiden wie kann man daraus lernen aber äh wir haben erstmal instrument was super
aber es ist gehört auch zu der ehrlichkeit eines eine solche mission dass man auch die kleinen probleme anspricht aber noch stolzer kann man ja sein wenn man mit diesem problem dann auch trotzdem ein guten stern katalog hinkriegt er für alle bereiche der astrophysik wirklich hervorragende daten liefern.
Man hat jetzt im wesentlichen eigentlich alles an bord und auch wenn das ein oder andere vielleicht unter den möglichen maximale erwartungen liegt dass man trotzdem weit über dem schweröl werten die andere mission bisher auf 'n tisch gelegt haben und es,
strömt ein ziemlich äh unerschöpflich eher strom von daten daher
der nun natürlich auch ausgewertet werden möchte werden jetzt schon darüber gesprochen wie viele mathematische modelle und prinzipiell e methoden hier zum einsatz kommen müssen ähm wie viele.
Wie viele gruppen sind jetzt hier ein
unmittelbar an dieses projekt angedockt und sind so first auf auf diese daten läuft das alles erstmal nur durch einen einzigen körper oder arbeiten da im prinzip alle sofort da dran und wo enden diese daten.
Ja das ist ganz unterschiedlich also erstmal das gesamte team was wir das.
Hatten analyse team von guyana pack also dieses konsorten das ist so das stichwort bei gaia das sind mehr als vierhundert leute die an den an einer auswertung der galeria daten arbeiten.
Und das wahrscheinlich weltweit.
Nicht weltweit das ist praktisch fast nur europa und wir haben uns ganz bewusst konzentriert das.
Bleibt es gibt nur ganz kleine beteiligung in usa und brasilien aber das sind wirklich nur ganz ganz wenige leute die da eine rolle.
Ist ja ein projekt und.
Wir haben das ganze organisiert in viele unter gruppen die sich mit den einzelnen aspekten der mission
beschäftigen es war so genauer gesagt neun große koordination juni also große koordinations einheiten in die das ganze geteilt ist und einige von denen beschäftigen sich erstmal unmittelbar damit aus den rohdaten
erstmal etwas überhaupt schon mal wissenschaftlich handhaben zu machen da diese prozesse laufen.
In der nähe in von madrid und die werden äh zum beispiel in dem fall
hauptsächlich von leuten aus barcelona deutschland software die diese umwandlung macht und äh dann
gibt es andere gruppen die dann zum beispiel den die daten sich die qualitätskontrolle der daten machen da läuft denn software auch in barcelona
von aus heidelberg und einigen anderen die sich an diesen first look beteiligen und
dann äh werden diese daten irgendwann nochmal genauer kalibriert das läuft dann auf einem superrechner in dem fall in barcelona
äh dort wo wo noch die sozusagen die qualifikation der daten verbessert wird und dann läuft äh diese astro mythische lösung die aus den einzelnen daten den sternen katalog macht äh das ist auch 'ne interaktive prozess nur nicht nur in dem sinne
wie ist das vorhin geschrieben hab sondern man will dann immer weiter verbesserungen auch der qualifikation vornehmen
um dann 'ne bessere lösung zu machen das ist 'n ganz wesentlicher punkt dann gibt es leute die sich damit beschäftigen mit der foto metro mit den spektren dann welche mit dem radio geschwindigkeit instrumenten
dann gibt es welche die sich damit beschäftigen dass die sterne die man hat auch äh klassifizieren werden also welche sterne sind das denn eigentlich die wir da messen.
Dann gibt es eine gruppe die sich damit beschäftigen wie
machen wir die daten am besten verfügbar das ist ja so dass natürlich die astronom auch zugriff auf die daten haben sollen und äh dann aufregende vernünftige art und weise
die daten zur verfügung gestellt bekommen das ist natürlich auch äh big data in gewissen weise dass man da viele milliarden messung
die dann auch noch die fehler und korrelation und was da alles 'ne rolle spielt enthält.
Also als solche gruppen wissen zusammenarbeiten und das schöne finde ich auch persönlich an so einem projekt ist dass es zeigt.
Pass mal mithilfe von wissenschaftlicher zusammenarbeit international auf die beine stellen kann dass man also mit einem großen team eine fast
unlösbare scheint der aufgabe am ende hinbekommt und dass die gruppen auch.
In einem positiven sinne zusammenarbeiten dass man auch an einem strang zieht und das zeigt dass man so mit europäische zusammenarbeit wissenschaftlich äh was ganz großartiges,
zustande bekommen hat was noch kein anderer hinbekommen hat kein amerikanisches projekt hat als solche daten bisher geliefert aber weltweit werden diese daten äh natürlich benutzt.
Klar und alle warten darauf dass sie auch möglichst schon runter gebrochen sind auf die essenz aber zunächst einmal hat man's ja mit den rohdaten zu tun und das spricht ja erstmal noch nicht so viel wahrheit.
Genau also die rohdaten müssen wie gesagt in wissenschaftliche daten umgewandelt werden und da steckt eine menge knowhow dahinter und was die wissenschaftler nachher haben wollen das natürlich alles schön aufbereitet damit sie.
Dann an die daten heran kommen können und das wird natürlich immer wenn wir so einen neuen katalog veröffentlicht bekommt die ihre neuen daten
aber das bis ganz besondere an gallia ist dass jeder weltweit zum gleichen zeitpunkt diese daten bekommt,
also auch die leute die sich an mit dem innerhalb des projektes arbeiten die daten natürlich im prinzip besser kennen und verstehen können haben dürfen nicht wissenschaftliche arbeit mit diesen daten machen bevor diese daten veröffentlicht sind.
Einer kleinen ausnahme wir müssen ja ein bisschen den
benutzer an den astronom zeigen dass man was man mit diesen daten anfangen kann deshalb gibt es ein paar diagramm paar daten die man schon mal
wissenschaftlich auswerten als demonstration der leistungsfähigkeit des,
bieten ohne solche sachen kann astronom auch nicht beurteilen was dahinter steckt deshalb sind solche wissenschafts- demonstrationen veröffentlichung äh sind sechzehn an der zahl die wir gemacht haben
wo die der satellit beschrieben wird die daten beschrieben werden aber auch solche wissenschafts- demonstration mit dabei sind,
das das wir zusammen sozusagen mit dem katalog dann veröffentlicht aber das besondere ist dass jeder ansonsten wird der minute wenn der wenn die archi dann angehen
die gleichen chancen haben und einige haben sich gut vorbereitet die haben sozusagen schon genau gewusst für welche objekte wollen sie gerne die entfernung die bewegung haben und die haben dann gleich die richtigen anfragen mit hilfe einer datenbank sprache.
An die äh sozusagen computer gestellt und gleich in dem moment wo dann der geöffnet worden gab's dann erstmal den ersten ansturm und schon wenige tage danach,
sind ja die erste veröffentlichung erschienen die sich gut vorbereitet haben
überraschende ergebnisse die dauern natürlich der lange länger weil man sich darauf nicht vorbereiten kann wirklich menge aber das ist wirklich grandios gewesen was da schon am anfang gekommen ist und bis heute.
Werden ungefähr vier wissenschaftliche arbeiten veröffentlicht pro tag.
Die daten benutzen seit dem fünfundzwanzigsten april seid wie diesen zweiten stern katalog der ja die den großen schritt der erste war so so 'n appetit hatten wir ein gewisser weise der seitdem nur aufgrund dieses jahr der zwei zwei wäre
ähm werden vier pro tag einschließlich samstag und sonntag.
Das sind tausendsiebenhundert papers die wir jetzt haben äh das ist wirklich grandios es gibt
kein soweit ich weiß kein projekt bei dem das solche großen zahlen von von äh daten auf grund irgendeine service in so kurzer zeit gegeben hat also langfrisst dich natürlich.
Wer veröffentlichungen aber die das projekt läuft ja auch schon.
Und das sind jetzt erstmal nur die niedrig hängenden früchte die hier.
Ja ich meine das sind schon sehr hohen gute früchte dabei also schön sehr reife und auch sehr sehr ordentliche früchte dabei aber in der tat
in der tat ist es so dass dass man natürlich erstmal das einfache macht aber jetzt kommen immer mehr paypal heraus wo man sieht mensch da da hat man auch jetzt längere zeit mit den daten gearbeitet um da dann auch was überraschendes und herauszufinden.
Dann schauen wir doch mal darauf
was wir jetzt eigentlich wissen was wir vielleicht vorher noch nicht gewusst haben oder was ich zumindest äh bestätigt hat was man vorher schon vermutet hat oder was vielleicht auch schon vollkommen,
ähm überraschend kam also wo man irgend einen neuen mysterium auf die spur gekommen ist also vielleicht nochmal kurz
ddr eins zwei wofür steht das genau delta release eins und zwei sind quasi immer noch so peter version von diesem stern katalog der erste war so.
Hier sind so die sterne wo sie sind und der zweite war jetzt äh haben wir noch mehr sterne und wo sie sind aber auch wie sie sich bewegen geschwindigkeit etcetera und ich glaube diese spektral information kam dann auch erst in dem ok.
Darf ich da vielleicht noch ergänzen bei dem ersten stern katalog hat man's immerhin schon durch einen kleinen trick auch geschafft für zwei millionen sterne
also der stein kalorien hier tatsächlich eins komma drei milliarden position am himmel die position am himmel ist nicht so die alle wertvollste informationen die bewegung die entfernung sind die wertvolle kombination.
Dadurch dass man der alte parcours sattel liegt noch messung hatte zweieinhalb millionen messungen
die man aber nicht dafür verwenden konnte dass man da positionen und eigene bewegung der sterne am himmel messen konnte dass dass man aber das war so hilfst instrument sozusagen mit dem man diese messung hatte.
Aus dem jahr im durchschnitt neunzehnhunderteinundneunzig stamm also da hat man so 'n langen zeitraum und warum das verglichen hat von vergleichen konnte mit den geier daten konnte man für zwei millionen von diesen zweieinhalb millionen tatsächlich
auch bewegung und paar relaxen noch nicht mit der tollen genauigkeit die wir jetzt der zweite stellen katalog enthält sondern mit einer etwas schlechteren aber
schöne guten hat man für zweieinhalb millionen sterne diese daten schon hat und dass man immerhin zwanzig mal mehr als man vorher überhaupt hatte.
Und diese sind schon gleich mit.
Genau.
Mit rein gerechnet worden und das war auch etwas was er überraschend war für viele was auch gar nicht geplant war aber nachdem man dann.
Herausbekommen hat dass man das machen konnte hat man sozusagen diese zwei millionen schon mal als appetit hat man die astronom gegeben,
und da wurden auch äh viele hundert papers mit gemacht mit diesem.
Ersten date release aber der große auch qualitative schritt der auch dann für viele schwächeren objekten äh ging
kam dann mit dem date bis zwei wo wir für eins komma drei milliarden sterne position bewegung
die helligkeit auch im blauen und im roten bereich sodass man was für die farben sagen konnte dass es also sozusagen so 'n richtig vollständiger daten
richtig astrophysik betreiben kann.
Und wie viele weitere lese soll es jetzt noch geben bis es dann ein finalen wird's wahrscheinlich geben irgendwann so ein finales mehr können wir nicht erzählen.
Genau das wird mit sicherheit kommen und.
Ob man später vielleicht immer nochmal was rausbringen kann aus den daten das wird man sehen denn man man kann gar nicht genug
kalibrieren und es noch besser machen aber irgendwann muss wird eine grenze durch die power gesetz bei so einem projekt also erstmal ist es so dass die zeiträume immer größer werden also.
Beim nächsten release das wird da wird ein erster teil den haben wir aufgeteilt in zwei ein olli und ein späteren release drei
der wird im dritten quartal des nächsten jahres also zweitausendzwanzig herauskommen und der rest der daten erst zweitausendeinundzwanzig also der wird so ein bisschen aufgespalten in einen ersten frühen daten satz wo die astronomie trixie und
die äh foto betrieb im blauen roten so wie wir es bei der zwei hatten schonmal veröffentlicht werden und dann kommt später daten für doppel.
Oftmals diese spektren dann auch äh als spektren herausgegeben
und äh viele neue daten für veränderlich sterne für asteroiden werden das sicherlich viel mehr sterne sein und für radikal geschwindigkeiten werden wir noch viel mehr daten dann kriegen also das wetter der der dritte das
dritte date wie wir das nennen das so ein bisschen in zwei teile aufgespalten ist und dann kommt der.
Der vierte date release was die daten von dem äh fünf jahren nominieren mission die wir jetzt sozusagen schon von der messung hier beenden.
Dann vollständig ausgewertet haben wird also wahrscheinlich werden alle daten äh bis zum ende zweitausend
neunzehn mit hineingehen und die werden dann analysiert und da wird man dann den daten satz machen und dann wird und da will man aber vollständig alles das was man im prinzip veröffentlichen kann.
Auch veröffentlichen und zwar wird das äh etwa dann äh so zweitausendzweiundzwanzig dreiundzwanzig kommen und dann.
Wenn wir die verlängerte mission je nachdem wie lange auch diese verlängerung und dann geht ob wir wirklich zehn jahre kriegen wird es dann natürlich nochmal ein endgültigen katalog der auch diese
längeren daten äh diese in diesem größeren daten satz und die mehr daten aufgrund der
größeren messi drums enthält noch drin sein das heißt am ende werden wir also fünf dieses diese geplant haben die wir geplant haben äh im sack haben.
Und das heißt wie groß ist dieser daten satz also.
Ja die frage ist wie viel das in in therapeut oder sowas sind nachher äh also die die jetzigen sternen kataloge das
hält sich in grenzen weil wir da sozusagen kompensiert die wichtigsten informationen der sterne drin haben aber zum beispiel spektren und solche dinge die die wir da und einzelne messungen die wir am ende auch
haben wollen wir wollen also auch nicht nur am ende sozusagen sagen welche
welche position bewegung und und entfernung haben die sterne sondern wo war zu den einzelnen mess punkten
das wollen wir den astronom auch herausgeben denn manchmal kümmern dann anhand bessere modelle für einzel sterne noch was mehr über die sachen aussagen und diese daten äh ich kann das gar nicht so ganz genau sagen und es wird wahrscheinlich dann in den therapeut bereich.
Gehen schätze ich äh was was diesen endgültigen katalog dann angeht im moment sind das eher so ein paar,
äh zig bis hundert gigabyte die da an daten vorhanden sind.
Jetzt frag ich mich natürlich was ist dabei
herausgekommen ich äh nämlich ich hab irgendwie vor ein paar monaten glaube ich so 'n vortrag von der wissenschaftlerin aus new york gesehen
wo auch schon ein paar ganz beeindruckende visualisierung dabei war wo vor allem schonmal so dieses etwas erschlagen ende
erschlagen information war wie viele sterne es gibt die einfach mit einem affenzahn in unserer,
umgebung durch die gegend rauschen und irgendwie ein vollkommen entkoppelt haben von der vorstellung des fix sterns ja,
diese ganze vorstellung dass das da oben irgendwie alles äh staates ist und sicher nichts bewegt
ja und es ist ja auch äh leute gibt die glauben das werden halt irgendwie immer noch so löcher in der schüssel,
die über uns herüber bestimmt hat aber nicht erst jetzt durch geier aber ich denk durch dieses datenmaterial nochmal auf eine ganz andere art und weise.
Bekommen wir offenbar ein bild eines doch sehr lebendigen sternen raums der sich zwar in einer geschwindigkeit abspielt wo wir mit dem bloßen auge halt keine chance haben aber das
schon eine langzeit beobachtung von in anführungsstrichen nur fünf jahren da auf einmal ein ganz anderes ergebnis bringt was.
Was offenbart uns jetzt dieser neue sternen katalog was was sehen wir.
Also das schwer zu sagen womit man anfangen soll aber ich versuch 's mal
also die bewegung der sterne sind in der tat geben ein unheimlich viel an informationen da gibt's erstmal einzelne objekte die sie ganz schnell laufenden sterne die sich teilweise mit tausenden von kilometern pro sekunde durch unsere milchstraße
bewegen dass die frage wie sind die eigentlich auf diese hohen geschwindigkeiten gekommen da gibt es ein paar ideen zum beispiel wenn ein stern ganz nah an dem zentralen schwarzen loch in unsere milchstraße vorbei
und das doppel stern ist dann kann eine komponente raus geschleudert werden aus dem system und ganz hohe geschwindigkeiten bekommen oder es gibt 'ne möglichkeit dass ein.
Also so 'n so 'n sonst black holz.
Genau genau genau und äh
es gibt eine andere möglichkeit dass zum beispiel hat man es bei weißen zwei drei weißen zwergen gefunden die wahrscheinlich auch folgende weise entstanden sind das sind zwei
weiße zwerge sind übrig sternzeichen die man sterne waren die brennen im inneren kein keine kernforderung wärst das gebiet motiviert mich lange zeit beschäftigt hab also bevor ich die gastronomiebetriebe macht doch zwischendurch immer noch ein bisschen aber
das ist nicht da bin ich nicht mehr so aktiv wie viele die jetzt die daten da benutzen.
So lagerfeuer glut äh.
Ja da gibt es drei objekte die man identifiziert hat aufgrund der geier die sich sehr schnell bewegen und.
Wo man folgende idee hatte sind zwei schwarz zwei weiße zwerge die umeinander ganz eng kreisen mit hoher geschwindigkeit von tausenden von kilometern pro sekunde wo einer von den beiden
'ne super lover explosion macht und dann ist die der partner weg.
Was passiert dann dann fliegt er andere sternen geradeaus weiter und mit der geschwindigkeit die er vorher im orbit hatte das ist so wie.
Nehmen sie den ball den sie an der schnur geschleudert und jetzt reiß dich nur weil da keiner.
Dann wieder beim erwerb genau die pflicht ist gerade aus und die solche objekte hat man da gefunden.
Aber was natürlich sozusagen abgesehen von solchen einzelne objekten übrigens bin ich auf einer konferenz in ende august hier in potsdam in der nähe von von berlin hier
da geht's um sterne also besonders schnell sterne und äh da geht's auch um die benutzung der geier daten damit ich auch ganz
spannend was da ein ergebnisse von den einzelnen wissenschaftlern kommen ich werd was über geier erzählt und die werden wir erzählen was man
mit der geier daten teilweise schon gemacht hat ähm da gibt es eben auch tolle ergebnisse wie wie ich gesagt hab aber interessant ist dass wir,
überhaupt die bewegung der.
Sterne in unseren weg straße so genau analysieren können denn es ist nicht so einfach so dass die sterne sieht so langweilig um die,
um das zentrum der galaxy bewegen sonne die man man kann was über die.
Vorgeschichte und die gesamte geschichte unsere milchstraße lernen äh wenn man die bewegung studieren dann sieht nämlich bewegungsmuster die man
teilweise nur dadurch erklären kann dass mal früher,
kleinere galaxien solche zwecke maxim in die milchstraße sich sehr stark genähert haben oder auch sogar richtig mit ihr verschmolzen sind und.
Die kollision.
Kollision genau auf kleinerer ebene hatte ich schon stattgefunden und zwar gibt es hinweise darauf dass zum beispiel vor zehn milliarden jahren eine
recht große
galaxy die damals ein viertel der masse der milchstraße hatte dass die milchstraße sogar noch gewachsen die hat ja sozusagen im laufe der zeit solche kleinen galaxien aufgefressen heute wäre es ein zehntel der masse der milchstraße aber immerhin schon ganz ordentlich das objekt so richtig nah an der milchstraße vorbeigegangen ist und.
Dadurch die sterne die ursprünglich in einer sehr dünn scheibe sich in der milchstraßen ebene gebildet haben.
Eine dicke scheibe verwandelt haben.
Und man hat sie diesen dieser.
Tätigen galaxy dies gibt damals gab auch namen gegeben geier in keller dos und ähm,
die diese diese galaxie ist also der erste hinweis und sieht ja gab's schon vorher so ideen dass es dir vielleicht gegeben hat aufgrund der geier daten können wir das
sehr genau studieren und zwar vor allen dingen auf
der betrachtung dieser sieben millionen sterne wo wir alle geschwindigkeit information in allen drei raum richtung haben und das kann man mit modellen vergleichen und dann,
ist die plausible erklärung tatsächlich das davor zehn milliarden jahren das gewaltiges passiert ist und das ist nicht das einzige ereignis dann gibt es hinweise darauf dass es vor.
Fünf hundert millionen jahren oder sucht zwischen hundert fünfzig und
fünfhundert millionen jahren eine weitere begegnungen mit der sage carius werk galaxy gegeben hat das ist auch eine von den zwei die man kennt
die so bestimmte schwingungen muster in nrw straße erzeugt haben die man ganz genau in den geier daten analysieren kann und
letztens hab ich dann noch ein dritten fall gehört dass es wahrscheinlich dass es eine neue entdeckte die man auf grund der geier daten
entdeckt hat antifa zwei heißt die wahrscheinlich noch weitere solche geschwindigkeit strukturen gegeben hat das heißt also in den geier daten in diesem geschwindigkeit.
Und den räumlichen informationen die man hat da steckt die milchstraßen geschichte.
Noch drin die wir heute noch sozusagen ablesen können zusammen mit modelle die wir über die milchstraße habt die wir daran testen können sodass wir das so die idee dass die milchstraße.
Kleineren galaxien ja verinnerlicht hat aber deren geschwindigkeit man teilweise noch als extra geschwindigkeit relativ zum rest,
erkennen kann diese idee dass die geier helfen soll die
geschichte und die entwicklung unsere milchstraße zu analysieren die hat sich wirklich äh hervorragender weise bestätigt dass wir schon nach einem jahr
jetzt solche dinge gefunden haben und ich bin sicher wenn man das jetzt noch genauer analysiert wird man noch weitere solche ereignisse identifizieren können und vieles über die geschichte.
Und die entwicklung unsere milchstraße aus dem gallia daten schließen können.
Vielleicht nochmal zum verständnis wie viele also wie viele sterne hat da jetzt.
Insgesamt gesehen einzelne sterne.
Ja weit mehr als zwei milliarden oder so zweieinhalb milliarden aber verdienen haben wir in den sternen katalog eins komma sieben gepackt weil das die sterne sind wo wir gute
gutes gefühl haben dass die daten gut genug sind dass sie veröffentlichen konnten und für eins komma drei milliarden haben wir eben diese diese gute information über bewegung entfernung und.
Aber unsere milchstraße darauf geht bestimmt die frage hinaus enthält natürlich.
Ich wollte gerade fragen also hundert milliarden ist so eine zahl die lange kolportiert wurde ich hab aber auch schon mal gehört es könnte.
Kann man denn jetzt sozusagen aus der den daten von geier auch extra polieren auf die größe der milchstraße oder korreliert das nicht wirklich und.
Was man was man relativ gut mit dem daten sagen kann ist die gesamtmasse der milchstraße aber einschließlich der.
Dunkle materie weil er mich zum beispiel bewegung von bestimmten sternen strömen die ausgebildet wurden durch zerrissene frühere.
Zwecke die mit unserem straße gravitation wechselwirkung getreten sind die denn zerrissen wurden der rennbahn sagen einem etwas darüber aus
wie viel masse drin ist oder die bewegung von sogenannten kugel stern haufen die man mit gaia gemessen hat die sagen etwas darüber aus aber diese die frage ist wie viel sterne das gibt es deutlich schwerer zu beantworten und wahrscheinlich wird sie immer mit einer gewissen messung genauigkeit sagen können
sehr präzise sagen können wird ist wie viele sterne ist in unserer sonne umgebung gab.
Und man denkt ja immer das wird man ja wahrscheinlich schon lange zeit gewusst haben aber selbst das ist nicht hundertprozentig bekannt und diesen wert wird man natürlich viel besser kriegen können weil man in der
umgebung der sonne natürlich alle sterne die es gibt mit gaia gemessen hat und auch deren entfernung
an einem ort zuordnen konnte und so dass man eine lokale bestandsaufnahme hat und natürlich kann man in gewisser weise diese zahl dann extra polieren und da muss man noch ein bisschen modellieren damit man andere effekte in der milchstraße mit berücksichtigt wird es natürlich 'ne gewisse unsicherheit geben also diese zahl wird wahrscheinlich
besser bekannt wird also ob es denn nun zwei oder dreihundert milliarden,
sterne sind das wird man vielleicht dann besser wissen aber es wird immer ein gewissen fehler auch aufgrund der galeria daten dann geben.
Aber man kann davon ausgehen so in der größenordnung von so einem prozent äh hat man schon das ist jetzt kein zu vernachlässigen da größenordnung also ist ja schon einiges.
Genau das ist wie bei einer meinungsumfrage da fragt man ja auch nur ein teil der leute um etwas über die gesamte gruppe zu lernen und äh.
Wenn man ein prozent der bevölkerung befragen würde wäre das schon.
Schon eine sehr sehr sehr gute menge klar ist
natürlich frage wie man muss natürlich immer rein die repräsentativ ist das für die gesamt gruppe weil man natürlich die sterne in der sonne umgebung beobachtet wäre es natürlich woanders andere sterne geben könnte das muss man das muss man natürlich andere messungen mit einbeziehen um eben auch solche
effekte abzuschätzen an an solchen stellen.
Wie weit in die milchstraße konnten wir schauen also sehen wir sterne die mehr oder weniger auf der anderen seite sind oder sind die einfach komplett auto oder.
Ja warum jetzt erstmal die frage warum kann man einen stern nicht mehr sehen mit geier das hat zwei gründe erstens erst nicht schwächer als unsere grenzen helligkeit von zwanzig komma sieben der größe das heißt wir würden also wenn wir wenn wir.
Keinerlei andere gründe hätten sterne die sehr hell sind noch sehr weit sehen wir können ja sogar sterne sehen die in der andere mit der galaxy sind haben wir ja gesagt oder in der
wolken nur die frage ist wie gut können wir zum beispiel daran entfernung messen noch und ähm die alle helfen sterne da können wir durchaus sagen aber bis zum rand der galaxy von uns ausgesehen.
Die sterne messen mehr probleme haben wir tatsächlich mit den steuern die auf der anderen seite der milchstraße sind.
Nicht im meer liegen den rand sondern.
Sondern der melia liegende rannte es leichter zu kriegen weil wir in eine andere richtung nämlich folgendes problem haben dass
überall in unsere milchstraße auch dunkel wolken drin sind gas und staubwolke die das licht der dahinter liegenden sterne verbergen und
kann man natürlich dann nicht mehr sehen weil sie einfach zu stark abgeschwächt werden durch diese dunkle wolken das heißt wir haben sozusagen ein gewisser weise ein löscht kriegen katalog
wo wir in bestimmten richtung wo wenig absolut option ist durch durch diese idealisten wolken können wir relativ weit sehen und in anderen richtung weniger und bevorzugt in der richtung richtung galaktisch das zentrum und.
Was das was man die andere,
da ist natürlich sehr sehr viel abstraktion zum beispiel können wir nicht das direkt ins galaktisch zentrum gehen da ist alles absolviert mit den daten in andere richtung hat man mehr chance das zu machen das ist in der tat ein gewisses problem
auch so 'ne karte dieser gas und dunkle wolken kann man übrigens dann aufgrund der geier da hatten erzeugen weil die natürlich
helfen zu sagen wo sind solche kumpel wolken in welcher entfernung stehen die weil man ja stern hat die davor sind und dahinter sind und in gewisser weise absolviert werden.
Schön wäre dass wenn man in zukunft mal ein satelliten hätte der mehr in infra roten arbeiten würde denn im infrarot kann man bisschen stärker
durch solche gas und staubwolke durchgucken äh also das ist es
durchsichtige sozusagen sind solche wolken dann da und das ist etwas was wo man durchaus überlegt für zukünftige mission.
Dass man das dass man dann mehr zu den längeren wählen den gibt.
Warum hat man so ein infrarot sein soll ich einfach noch mit in die sensoren kette mit reingebaut.
Erstens weil die astro materie.
Besser ist hier kurzweiliger etwas ist das gerade das gegenteil weil die auflösung vermögen eines teleskop.
Bei gegebener größe eines teleskop ist es besser wenn man zu kurzen wählen die gibt das ist der eine grund.
Der andere ist dass das was man dieses geschichte das also so 'n so 'n rotieren in satellit hat wo die foto ton in den cds genau mit der geschwindigkeit ausgelesen werden wie sie auch über die cd ebene wandern.
Solche gibt es.
Gar nicht infrarot solche solche diktatoren und man macht grad 'ne studie ob man sowas herstellen könnte das heißt da ist man technologisch weiß man noch nicht genau ob man darauf mit den gleichen prinzip machen könnte man könnte natürlich andere.
Prinzipien machen zum beispiel einfach.
Sozusagen himmels aufnahmen von bestimmten gegenden zu machen aber da da hat man nicht diese schöne verbindung alle teile des himmels miteinander wie man in einer solchen mission wie geier hat aber solche mission wir sind geplant zum beispiel die.
Japaner haben ein projekt dass ich äh jasmin äh.
Jasmin heißt das nächste projekt wo wo sie so ein bisschen mehr in richtung galaktisch zentrum aufnahmen machen wollen die astro methodisch vermessen werden aber im prinzip benutzen sie dann damit man das alles als ein stabiles system für die daten von den stern die man gemeinsam drin hat.
Um daraus dann diese bilder zu kalibrieren also äh aber der zukünftige geier die dann auch ins training ist das hängt eben noch davon ab
das technologisch äh auf diese weise möglich ist und das wird sicherlich auch eine jahrzehnte brauchen bevor das so etwas dann wieder verwirklicht wurde.
Albert einstein hat ja seinen großen durchbruch nachdem man mal konkret mit 'ner beobachtung belegen konnte dass der von ihm vorgesagt gravitationswellen effekt also die tatsache das
die gravitation die ja beschrieben hat tatsächlich in der lage ist licht auch
zu lassen und dann konnte man halt auf einmal sterne sehen von den man zwar wusste dass jeder der sonne waren aber bei einer sonnenfinsternis wurde
sie schauen irgendwie noch so um die ecke herum ähm
mein verständnis jetzt ist dass wenn wir jetzt so genau alles beobachten dass wir im prinzip ja auch schwarze löcher aus diesem datenmaterial.
Irgendwie herauslesen könnten weil wir dann sozusagen aus unterschiedlichen positionen die bewegung kriegen und dann müsste der stern da sein aber von der anderen seite.
Es hat nicht da wo er sein müsste weil da so ein effekt war also.
Ja ja ja ja nicht ganz aber ist im prinzip hast du recht das ist es so dass sie nicht in der tat von starken gravitationswellen abgelenkt wird aber da das alles sehr kleinen räume strukturen sind wird man das nicht
zu sagen aber es aber es spielt auf eine andere weise eine rolle
dadurch dass du einen lichtstrahl an unser durch unser sonnensystem fliegt passiert genau das was bei dieser messung zwei neunzehnhundertneunzehn bei dieser berühmten messung am sonnenstrand
gewesen ist wo das team von gemessen hat wie stark wird das licht in der nähe
der sonnenschein wenn es bei wenn sie bei einer sonnenfinsternis für dunkel wird abgelenkt relativ zu der position die sie ohne die sonne hätte das hat.
Wurde er damals gemessen war der große durchbruch für die allgemeine relativitätstheorie die bestätigung dass die absicht ablenkung nach der formel funktioniert die auch von der,
allgemeine relativitätstheorie vorhergesagt wurde aber haben wir zwar einerseits den punkt das gar ja nie mehr.
Mir als sterne misst die näher als fünfundvierzig grad an der sonne dran sind aber.
Da dieser effekt zwar kleiner ist fünfundvierzig grad weg von der sonne und über den bereich bis hundert fünfunddreißig grad weg von der sonne mascara ja immer.
Dass die ähm dass diese effekte kleiner sind aber immer noch so groß weil die messe genauigkeit natürlich heute so viel größer ist und zwar neunzig grad also am direkt am sonnenbrand ist ja die licht ablenkung sowas wie äh.
Eins komma was ist das eins komma drei bogen sekunden.
Und immerhin neunzig grad weg von der sonne ist der effekt immer noch vier bogen minuten also etwas was auch die parkhaus schon messen konnte und was man bei der.
Datenverarbeitung natürlich berücksichtigen musste das,
abgelenkt ist und der stern gar nicht in der position ist wo man gesehen hat sondern man muss diese licht ablenkung berücksichtigen und bei gaia sind vier millimeter sekunden natürlich etwas was man noch viel weiter aufschlüsselung kann weil wir ja in die,
bei den besten sternen sowas wie zwanzig dreißig bogen mikro bogen sekunden also millionsten sekunden messen können das heißt also wir müssen über den gesamten bereich wo wir die geier messung haben die licht ablenkung an der sonne mitberücksichtigen.
Aber bei gaia kommt jetzt noch was ganz großes hinzu sogar die licht ablenkung an den großen planeten spielt 'ne rolle also die verschiebung.
Wir waren so und jetzt nimmt und äh guckt äh so vielleicht zehn zwanzig grad weg vom jupiter dann ist die
licht ablenkung dort immer noch in der größenordnung von einigen zehn mikro bogen sekunden das heißt etwas was wir im prinzip bei den geier daten berücksichtigen müssen und was auf zur vermessung
wichtig ist also da spielt die ihre allgemeine relativitätstheorie 'ne große rolle und in gewisser weise benutzen wir die allgemeine relativitätstheorie bei jeder auswertung jedes einzelnen sterne es.
Und insofern eine.
Die relativitätstheorie allgemeine sowieso eine der best bestätigten theorien von von der messung her die es überhaupt in der physik.
Also schwarze löcher kann man nicht.
Kann man nicht wenn aber du hast erwähnt in.
Linsen effekt es ist in der tat ja so dass es gravitationswellen essen gibt bei denen sich ein sternen vor einen anderen schiebt und der sozusagen dann als linse wirkt.
Und ähm sowas hat man sowas führt zu einer verstärkung des lichtes dahinter liegenden stern ist das hat man das wird ganz häufig gemessen durch
projekte wo man zum beispiel in richtung galaktisch im zentrum viele sterne beobachtet die dann solche helligkeit ausbrüche haben oder verstärkung des lichtes haben die man auf die grund des
gravitationswellen effekte sieht aber der witz ist egal ja kann man ja wissen wie sich die sterne bewegen man hat ja eine sternen katalog.
Und dann kann man in einigen fällen vorhersagen dass ein solcher gravitationswellen effekt wirklich passiert.
Weil man weiß wann der eine hinter dem anderen ist aus sicht der erde und dann wird der heller und.
Ganz genau solche vorher sagen gibt es jetzt und äh da bin ich jetzt gespannt auf die ersten daten das auch bestätigen dass man sowas dann gesehen hat und.
Was er dann wiederum auch eine bestätigung der daten wäre was ja auch mal ganz interessant ist weil bisher nur nimmt man die daten jetzt quasi als die wahrheit aber
über diese art und weise kann man dann sozusagen auch die daten selber nochmal genau bestätigen.
Ähm
noch so ein gedanke äh einer meiner lieblingsstadt der letzten jahre auf die so gestoßen wann ist das schöne worte also,
der große struktur des universums wurden über längere zeit ja der lauf von vielen galaxien und galaxien klasse also fangen die größte strukturen die wir überhaupt kennen oder zumindest bis dahin definiert hatten
beobachtet und es wurde halt festgestellt das obwohl bestimmte galaxien vielleicht in etwa bäume nämlich in einer ähnlichen
nähe waren sie mit nichten teil der selben struktur waren sondern dass da sozusagen nochmal verbotene geflüchtete gibt.
An hand eben dieser langzeit bewegung
der galaxien und lavia ist sozusagen die bezeichnung das ist sozusagen ist die größte postleitzahl die wir haben ja also so milchstraße ist da nur ein ein kleiner punkt da drin aber wir wissen dass wir dann sozusagen in so einem im größten von uns
beobachten waren
gewebe struktur da ein teil von sind und das andere was uns vielleicht relativ nah ist nicht zwangsläufig dazu gehört weil wir nicht in diesem selben
gravitation pool irgendwie mit drin seid wenn wir jetzt.
Insbesondere den die umgebung der erde so gut beobachtet haben wie wir es jetzt eben haben mit gaia lassen sich darauf
vergleichbare meter strukturen die so vielleicht derzeit noch gar nicht definiert sind in der milchstraße weil wir haben halt so
ja okay die erde ist halt sonnensystem und sonst milchstraße und bei der scheren dimension dieser galaxis
fehlt mir so ein bisschen so die die definition der nachbarschaft ja da fliegen halt sterne mit großer geschwindigkeit vorbei die gehört zu irgendeiner ehemaligen galaxie also sind sie ja ganz offensichtlich nicht.
Teil unseres unmittelbaren bezug systems andere wiederum die wir vielleicht gar nicht so sehr im verdacht hatten weil sie relativ weit weg waren aber sehr wohl weil sie sich irgendwie insgesamt,
anderen sternen und sonnen äh ja in dem selben dieselben bewegungsform bewegen also gibt
das da überhaupt schon solche definition oder ist absehbar dass wir jetzt sowas vielleicht daraus generieren.
Ja es ist nie ausgeschlossen ist man vielleicht neue solche strukturen entdeckt aber erstmal die milchstraße hat ja schon eine gewisse struktur wir haben erstmal den
verdickungen in der mitte wo wir sogar wissen dass das so 'ne balken förmlich struktur ist äh die kann man auch teilweise auflösen mit hilfe von stern und die struktur dieser dieses balken ist genau erkennen dann haben wir
die genetische ebene und dann haben wir ein hallo um diese straße herum wo sich viele sterne befinden die auch
teilweise natürlich entstanden sind durch solche verschmelzen prozesse mit ähnlich.
Mit anderen zweck galaxien wo sowieso ströme haben von stern die sozusagen so die die die die den galaktisch hallo umgeben.
Was natürlich wird zusätzlich noch haben sind zum beispiel die spirale strukturen in der galaxis die frage ist zum beispiel wo sind die spirale arme in unserer galaxis und das ist etwas was.
Gar nicht so leicht aus der geier daten heraus destillieren ist denn äh die spirale arme sind da wo.
Mein junge sterne hat und der muss man die sogenannte ganz genau die sterne selektieren die jungen sind und weil die spirale arme sind die awo sterne entstehung stattfindet und wo also ein stern nur sterne dann auch direkt
dort noch vorhanden sind die nur wenige million jahre.
Worauf kann man worauf kann man das alter nochmal ablesen und wir feiern helfen die geier da.
Genau die das alter der sterne hin ganz wesentlich mit der masse eine sterns zusammen unsere sonne hat ja ein alter von etwa viereinhalb milliarden jahren und wird in der jetzigen bremsphase von
von clean reaktionen die es im inneren gibt noch ungefähr genauso lange.
Lieben ungefähr ein weitere vier fünf milliarden jahren es hat also so etwa da haben wir so etwa halbzeit das heißt unsere sonne hat ungefähr so 'ne
so ein alter in ihrer jetzigen brennen phase von zehn milliarden jahren aber es gibt sterne die,
masse reicher sind und jede masse reicher in stern ist da denkt man das müsste eigentlich am längsten leben sondern sterne mehr masse hat hat auch mir treibstoff also wo wasserstoff dann zu helium
fusionieren werden kann nein die jemals erreichen stern ist dass du verschwenderisch er geht mit der energie um und.
Desto kürzer lebten sterns und stern von äh von zehn sonnen massen oder so der lebt eben nur so 'ne million oder zwei millionen jahre und.
Sportwagen die früher an der ampel kollidieren.
Na ja und und wenn man die eben findet in der nähe der äh guckt äh die die können sich noch nicht so weit von ihrem geburtsort entfernt haben während unsere sonne.
Von ihrem geburtsort sie schon sehr sehr weit weg sein können äh kann innerhalb der viereinhalb milliarden jahren kann vier passieren aber innerhalb von wenigen millionen jahren passiert noch nicht so viel und
diese ähm jungen sterne sagen einmal so wo sozusagen die geburtsort da sind und.
Da ist gibt es zuerst hinweise da dass die spirale struktur der milchstraße vielleicht nicht ganz so.
Klare spirale strukturen zeigt wie wie das so auf den typischen bildern die die oft ja aus daten
zwar stamm aber die auch so ein bisschen künstlerische freiheit enthalten äh.
Dass die nicht so klare spirale strukturen hat sondern auch viele sterne oder auch sterne steht gebiete so zwischen den haupt spirale arm sind also es gibt so eine klasse von galaxien die man äh.
So flockig galaxie nennt und vielleicht ist sonne sonne so ein bisschen mehr so eine galaxy das sind das ist etwas für so 'ne rolle spielen können.
Die milchstraße meine unsere galaxy die milchstraße.
Also das etablierte bild was man alles so kennen so dieses foto existiert ja nicht weil woher aber kann sein dass es alles ganz anders.
Das kann sein dass dass man das zumindest modifizieren muss und das muss man natürlich zusammen mit anderen beobachtungen zum beispiel radio beobachtung wo man die,
die häufigkeit des wasserstoff gases was auch was zu tun hat wenn die sterne entstehungsgeschichte dass man das alles zusammen führt und dann am ende der mission wollen relativ.
Bild wie die spirale struktur unsere milchstraße wirklich es ist aber es gibt alles deutet sich an dass da die sterne nicht ganz so konzentriert
wie man's vielleicht bisher dachte aber das ist 'ne recht vorläufige aussage und die muss natürlich aufgrund der weiteren.
Aber so zu sagen zu der lokalen gruppe so wir und unsere paar nachbarn galaxien sowas gibt's.
Ja du wirst dich jetzt nicht wie man das jetzt so als direktes equipment.
Kann ja sein dass er so was weiß ich äh tausend sonnen gibt die alle irgendwie mehr oder weniger mit derselben geschwindigkeit in dieselbe richtung treiben und andere treiben andere.
Ja sowas sowas gibt's natürlich sowieso das sind das sind das nennt man sterne kaufen oder solche stern ströme die die haben also die sterne kaufen es ist ja so dass sterne oft nicht in alleine geboren werden sondern
wenn aus einer großen moleküle wolke die sich den qualitativ zusammenhänge
zieht gleich mehrere sterne geboren werden teilweise tausend und manchmal sogar zehntausende von stern die dann gemeinsam geboren sind die.
Sie beobachten ja derzeit nur woanders nicht bei uns selber.
Ja aber die beobachten wir durchaus in der sonne umgebung solche stern haufen die daraus mal geworden sind.
Gibt es den stern haufen der unserer ist und hat der namen.
Ja das ist 'ne gute frage ob wir ob unsere sonne mal teil eines stern hoffen's war das wissen wir bis heute nicht und wäre eine gute idee ob man das vielleicht herausfinden kann
war also bei vielen sternen kaufen haben wir jetzt zum beispiel gesehen so stern hoffen dann löst sich auch im laufe der zeit aus da sind der begegnet einerseits zu.
An einem großen moleküle wolken die haben ziemlich viel masse die können so einen stern haufen auseinander reisen oder auch überhaupt nur das gravitationswellen potential unsere milchstraße die ganze materie da drin ist die zieht am ende
das hat man gezeiten kräfte die sterne aus so einem stern haufen heraus und das schöne ist dass man handle geier daten
herausfinden kann welche sterne noch ungefähr die gleiche bewegungs richtung haben wie die sterne die zu diesem stand haufen gehört und dann kann man kann man sehen
wie der sich im laufe der zeit auflösung ich habe mal das an die hürden an den an der präsident das sind so bekannte stern haufen die man sogar teilweise bloßem auge sehen kann hat man jetzt gefunden wie weit die sterne inzwischen teilweise rausgerissen sind die man gar nicht ohne diese
bewegungsenergie information wie man sich von geier hätte mit dem stern hof noch 'n zusammenhang bringen konnte.
Es solche sachen gibt es oder die wie ich vorhin sagte diese diese
alle zwei oder auch kugel stern haufen die vom von der von der milchstraße aufgrund dieser,
gezeiten kräfte zerrissen wurden die bilden so richtig ströme am himmel die sich in eine richtung in am arbeit um die milchstraße herum bewegen und.
Die kann man dann finden auf grund der geier daten teilweise hat man natürlich auch schon vorher aufgrund solcher besserung
die man von der erde ausgemacht hat äh gesehen solche strukturen aber mit geier kann man mehrere mehr solche strukturen entdecken und natürlich viel genauer analysieren.
Was gibt's denn sonst noch so für interessante partie rausgekommen sind weil warum haben sie sich denn jetzt alle gestürzt also es ist ja drauf gewartet umso paar sachen festzustellen was ist denn da so die schöpfung höher derzeit.
Ja also ganz stark sind sind diese strukturen von denen ich tragt wo es darum geht was war die vergangenheit unsere milchstraße
diese bewegung strukturen aber auch die untersuchung ganz bestimmt der stern klassen spielt 'ne rolle zum beispiel bei den weißen zwergen das ja mein altes gebiet wo ich natürlich genau gucken was da passiert da gibt es ungefähr so
dreißig veröffentlichung die sich nur mit dieser sterne gruppe beschäftigen und da hat man etwas gefunden was ganz ganz interessant ist was man im prinzip von der theorie schon vorher gesagt hat das nämlich wenn sterne weiße zwerge sind sterne die mal.
Sterne waren im grunde stern leichen die wo keine kern fusion mehr stattfindet um sie am leuchten zu halten und.
Also die lagerfeuer.
Genau genau.
So es ist noch ein bisschen warm sind die schon noch aber das war's.
Genau unsere sonne wird zum beispiel in etwa vier bis fünf milliarden jahren ein weißer zwerg und wird dann noch ungefähr die halbe masse haben die die sie jetzt hat und
nur noch so groß sein wie die erde und dann ist natürlich die dichte der materie viel viel größer und.
Diese sterne kühlen dann nur noch im laufe der zeit.
Und da wir jetzt mit gaia ganz ganz viele weiße zwerge neu gefunden haben also bisher kannte man dreißigtausend weiße zwerge und jetzt haben wir mit gaia.
Zweihundertsechzigtausend.
Gemessen also zwei dreißigtausend neue gemessen die mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit weiße zwerge sind dass es nicht in jedem einzelfall hundert prozent sicher aber
bei den meisten ist das sicher also wie viel größeres asambley haben wir da plötzlich vor uns wissen auch wie viele objekte ist dann froh
volumen intervalle gibt also weil wir dir dann viel besser messen kann und die hat man auch da
hat man auch da natürlich die foto mit trier und alles genau untersucht und da hat man herausgefunden dass äh.
Dass die weißen zwerge von der theorie her irgendwann so kühl werden dass dann plötzlich die rest wärme
in den weißen zwergen dazu führt dass die kristallisieren wie man sagt dass der plötzlich die atom rufe ein kristall gitter bilden und die atome dann da nur noch hin und her schwingen so 'n bisschen wien.
Bestehend aus kohlenstoff vor der sauerstoff in das ist ein bisschen wie 'n großer diamant kohlenstoff es wäre wäre auch so 'ne kristalle struktur nur ist der abstand der atome da ungefähr zweihundert mal kleiner als in einem diamant und
dabei ja genau super diamant und der dabei wird wärme frei das heißt da wird kurzzeitig das abkühlen ein bisschen aufgehalten.
Und das kann man ganz genau sehen dass in bestimmten teilen des zab kühl sequenz wie man das nennt die sterne häufiger sind
das ist einfach so weil sie da verlangsamt werden also statt weiter abzukühlen kriegen sie so ein bisschen weiter wieder wärme.
Und kühlen dann bisschen langsamer ab für 'ne gewisse zeit.
Das heißt sie halten sich in diesem bereich ein bisschen länger auf das so ein bisschen wie beim auto stau wenn wenn wir dann plötzlich unsere geschwindigkeit von langsam sind da finden wir da mehr,
autos rückstau und und diese die hatten wir jetzt identifiziert in bestimmten diagramm physikalischen diagramm wo man diese strukturen sehen konnte und,
äh konnte direkt sagen unsere theorie ist auf diese weise bestätigt worden.
Von was für frequenzen reden wir da also tausende.
Geht über hunderte von millionen jahren solche solche abkühlung und bis hin zu milliarden jahren.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so eine pause eintritt bis es dann wieder schneller ist das.
Ja das das das sind das sind äh das können durchaus einige millionen jahren sein die das die das die da eine rolle spielen und die die die sorgen dafür dass wir da mehr objekte finden in dieser dieser phase dann.
Ok also ich sage jetzt schon das ist der neue pulse.
Nein nein nein das ist nicht aber es gibt auch da so gut das hat man vorausgesagt und das konnten wir jetzt aber wirklich zeigen dass die modelle wirklich toll sind das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
schön dass ihr einfach irgendwas überraschendes findet und bei den gibt es sterne die im prinzip das machen was unsere sonne macht nämlich im zentrum wasserstoffzug umwandeln die aber viel weniger masse haben als die als die sonne und die.
Da gibt es da hat man gefunden wenn man die sich aufzeichnet dass es da eine lücke gibt wo.
Ok los keine weißen keine keine roten zwerge wie man die nennt gibt und diese.
In dem diagramm ist wirklich so klar zu sehen und die hat kein mensch vorhergesagt aufgrund der modelle die wir vorher von den stern haben und.
Dann hat man sich genau angeguckt wann passiert diese lücke und das ist genau dann wenn der wenn die innere struktur dieses dieser sterne sich ändert.
Im inneren der sonne wird wird die.
Ähm durch strahlung erstmal bis zu etwa zwei drittel ihres radios transportiert und den äußeren sohn da steigen gas massen auf und wieder runter das nennt man konvention und wenn man dann stern
immer niedrigere masse hat auf der in der gleichen phase wie die sonne es hat dann wird ein stern immer.
Kollektiver das heißt bis zum kern geht dann irgendwann werden steigen die elemente auf oder runter da wird nicht mehr die energie weitgehend durch strahlung transportiert sondern durch solche aufsteigen elemente und da wo dieser übergang stattfindet dass der sterne plötzlich voll konfetti v wird da gibt's diese lücke.
Und die muss man jetzt ganz genau untersuchen ob ein und und und sagen
passt das jetzt ganz genau mit der mit der phase wo da stattfindet verglichen mit unseren modellen da sieht man dann plötzlich strukturen die man nicht gesehen hat und
die zum verständnis wieder stern aufgebaut ist dann äh wesentliche neue informationen liefert also solche überraschenden dinge finde ich natürlich immer noch mit am spannend.
Gesehen jetzt von diesen konkreten studien die sich jetzt sozusagen an dem modell als solchen abarbeiten
ist ja der stern katalog jetzt auch im prinzip so der der neue brock haus äh sozusagen der astronomie also man kann ja dann hier sozusagen
alles auf viel verlässlicheren daten basieren also es geht ja dann auch für mission etcetera was könnte das noch so für auswirkungen haben und generell was zeichnet sich sagen wir mal jetzt in dieser flo wissenschaftliche untersuchung
ab oder was wird vielleicht erst jetzt vorstellbar was so vorher noch gar keine basis hatte.
Man also ich glaub es hauptsächlich wird es erstmal sein dass man einfach immer genauer hingeguckt weil man.
Immer bessere daten bekommt jeder katalog ist besser als der vorherige und äh der große schritt war tatsächlich der zum zum zweiten stern katalog den so ein großer schritt,
wird es eigentlich nie wiedergeben auch auf wenn gar jetzt sozusagen den endgültigen katalog bekommt bekommen wir von der daten lage her
nochmal etwas besseres wir können auf den diese spektren zusätzlich und mehr mehr information aber so einen großen schritt
der war schon fundamental an der stelle und.
Ich würde sagen es wird viel genauer noch die ganze kinematic die bewegung in unsere milchstraße das wird immer noch das hauptthema auch der zukunft bleiben das genauer zu analysieren etwas über die.
Die vergangenheit vielleicht auch über die zukunft der milchstraße man an die kollision mit dem drum wieder nebel denkt dass man all das genauer untersuchen wird man wird.
Die sterne modelle verbessern man wird also,
die geier daten hat man ganz starke randbedingungen dafür wie sterne wirklich sind weil man die bisher ja von der erde aus nicht so genau beobachten konnte mussten die modelle auch nicht so gut sein das heißt das ist jetzt so dass der.
Die beobachtung einen großen schritt gemacht hat zu der hohen genauigkeit und die muss dann auch erstmal erklärt werden und da wird es auch immer einzeln objekte geben die man überhaupt
nicht mehr versteht weil die irgendwie strukturen zeigen die man nicht gehabt hat da müssen wir neu erklärung her und.
Dann glaube ich dass es immer wieder überraschung geben wird die ich jetzt nicht denke und niemand gedacht hat,
was ist da an verborgenen geheimnisse in so einem stern katalog ist und das wird aus welchen gebiet das kommt ist fast nicht vorher zu sehen also
ich hab mal versucht so 'ne liste aus themengebieten wo gar eine rolle spielt in der in den astro physikalischen literatur und das sind glaube ich so dreißig vierzig.
Und in allen hat gar ja irgendwelche beiträge schon geliefert und das wird immer weitergehen und die genauigkeit wird das heißt man hat immer eine.
In gewisser weise eine schärfere brille mit der man die strukturen in unsere milchstraße und bei einzelnen sternen äh am ende sehen kann aber vorher sage ich bin da.
Ich denke dass man vielleicht auch noch in hundert jahren in den geier da hatten was entdecken kann also das sind so langfristiger und fundamentaler
ja blockhaus hast du es genannt äh der der wirklich für die astrophysik ein unschätzbar schatz sein wird und das wichtige ist diese daten dann mit anderen beobachtung wie ich da schon mal angedeutet hab zusammenzubringen dass man
auf anderen gebieten kann man durchaus von der erde oder auch mit teleskop oder so weitere informationen über die objekte zu bekommen aber die geier daten werden immer noch wichtige zusatzinformationen jeweils dazu liefern so dass da ein gesamtbild entsteht aber was das in der zukunft dann äh
sein wird da das weiß ich nicht und lasse ich mich auch gerne überraschen.
Ich denke eine neue sportart die jetzt hier vielleicht geboren werden kann das so ein bisschen die astro visualisierung nicht dass die noch nicht gegeben hat aber die daten sind ja alle öffentlich sind sehr genau sind sehr umfangreich das ist ja dann sagen wir mal ganz unabhängig davon dass sie
quasi die wahrheit
bildet ist es natürlich auch eine eine wunderbar natürliche partikel wolke mit der man irgendwie nett arbeiten kann es gab ja schon einige ganz interessante visualisierung ich hab's vorhin angesprochen allein dieser eine vortrag hatte mich schon damit
durchschlagenden
recht beeindruckt könnte mir vorstellen dass da schon noch so einiges gibt und sich auch noch das ein oder andere anbahnt aber das ist ja dann auch ein hervorragendes datenmaterial für leute die vielleicht generell einfach erstmal mit astronomie so gar nichts zu tun haben aber wiederum spezialisten sind im visualisierung bereich.
Ja da gibt es natürlich immer wissenschaftliche
animation die natürlich etwas darstellen was man wissenschaftlich gefunden hat aber es gibt auch es gibt auch das was man eben
für die allgemeine öffentlichkeit hat dass man dass man ja visualisierung habt die einfach den gesamten katalog darstellen wo sind die sterne wie bewegen sie sich im laufe der zeit und da haben wir in heidelberg ein programm entwickelt insbesondere meinen.
Kollege tod dieser christa der wirklich ein meister sei der programmierung ist der der ausbildung in der astrophysik hat und in computer wissenschaften und der ein programm gebaut hat was sich gas keine nimmt
das programm kann jeder
ähm der ein computer hat für für für windows oder für 's runterladen zusammen mit dem stern katalogen und was man da machen kann ist dass man dann durch den stern katalog hindurch fliegen kann und.
Gucken kann wo sind die sterne sowie
ja raumschiff enterprise was auch immer nur dass die sterne wirklich da sind wo sie auch wirklich sind in den sternen katalog und das ganze,
geht vom sonnensystem bis hin zu den sternen die von gaia gemessen wurden bis hin zu einigen hundert millionen sterben die wir in den katalog haben aber es fängt im sonnensystem an das heißt da werden wir können zum beispiel
mit diesen mit diesen programm gucken,
wo steht gar ja selber gerade relativ zur erde zu den anderen körpern und unserem sonnensystem wie in welche richtung steht gar ja grade wie rotiert gar ja wir können nämlich die zeit eine einschalten und dann auch einfach schnell ablaufen lassen sehen wir wie geier sich bewegt
und wir sehen dann wenn wir ganz schnell das ganze bewegen wie sich die sterne bewegen das heißt wir können uns angucken wie wird der sterne.
Sternenhimmel in einigen hunderttausend jahren einigen millionen jahren sein.
Und wie bewegen sich die sterne wenn man einfach deren jetzige bewegung extra poliert und da kann man eben einfach mal ein zeitraffer einschalten und dann sieht man zum beispiel dass die sterne eine stern haufen sich alle
in die gleiche richtung bewegen und äh man kann gucken wie die asteroiden in unserem sonnensystem sich bewegen es ist also etwas was ich wirklich jeder der lust hat an solchen dingen.
Äh ans herz legen kann
dass man mal so kleine flügel durch die galaxie schneller als das licht.
Und äh mal so die lieblings sterne die man kennt.
Sich anguckt und da hinfliegt und ähm.
Das ist wirklich ein großartiges programm und in einer version die jetzt auch noch weiterentwickelt wird für die im moment geht das nur für windows aber das wird auch wieder noch ein anderen kommen.
In der v r brille sich die sachen auch angucken dann kann man in allen richtungen also dreihundertsechzig grad in allen richtungen
sich die objekte angucken man kann mit einer rot-grünen brille wenn man sie hat auch dreidimensional die sachen sehen wenn man ein fernseher hat der
drei d ist kann man sogar auch da die
die sterne dreidimensional direkt auf dem bildschirm sehen mit der mit den entsprechenden brillen die man dann dazu geliefert hat also.
Programm ist wirklich etwas was
was großartig ist und was wir auch dann benutzen um bestimmte wissenschaftliche dinge
dann für die öffentlichkeit aufzubereiten das man sich versteht und dass man die mission kennt dass man wissenschaftliche ergebnisse visualisieren kann also kleine videos gibt es die findet man zum beispiel auch auf meinem oder christus youtube.
Da findet man so einiges an anfertigen videos aber äh das spannendste ist natürlich dass man jeder dass jeder selber mal sich dieses programm unterlegt und ähm ja so 'n klein bisschen spaß mit dem zweiten stern katalog von gala hat und irgendwann spaß mit den
späteren katalogen die noch kommen wird.
Ja schöne zeiten brechen an vor allem für plane szenarien die ihr natürlich dann auch nochmal ganz andere datenbasis haben zu visualisierung mit zunehmenden
digitalisierung von planetarium den kann man natürlich dass dann in der perspektive nochmal viel besser.
Stefan.
Ich frage jetzt nicht aber irgendwas wichtiges vergessen weil da gibt's bestimmt wir können wahrscheinlich stundenlang äh weiter quatschen aber vielleicht hast du noch irgendein schlusswort oder eine abschließende betrachtung die den ganzen nachstellen willst was wir jetzt schon.
Also ich ich glaube.
Das was mich am mal so überrascht hat ich hatte gesagt ich komme aus einem ganz anderen gebieten und hab mir gedacht ja astrid ist 'ne tolle grundlage und äh muss ich aber nicht selber machen und bin dann so ein bisschen daher reingeraten
dass ich eine stelle suchte und äh dann erstmal mit dem deutschen projekt was nicht zustande kam da mich beschäftigt hatte und ich sehe jetzt was für
wissenschaftliche art mathematische art von verständnis her diese diese diese astronomie try leistet und
dass das daten sind die man wahrscheinlich über jahrzehnte jahrhunderte verwenden wird um tolle erkenntnisse über unser universum zu bekommen vom
von den asteroiden bis zu der frage wie schnell sich unser weltall ausdehnt also das alles fragen wo gar ja dat eine rolle spielen wird und diese diese um fassung des gesamten gebietes
mit hilfe dieses projektes was zum direkt oder indirekt auf diese teile einfluss haben wird die finde ich wahnsinnig
hoffe ich auch dass das ein bisschen vielleicht bei den zuhörern ja zumindest hier rüber kommt dass das 'ne.
Spannende weltraum mission ist und ein paar jahrzehnte muss natürlich dann irgendwann nachfolger noch bessere daten äh dazufügen denn wenn die sterne
sich weiter bewegt haben werden auch die messe fehler wieder größer und wir brauchen irgendwann eine neue mission.
Das äh das wird dann also sozusagen die die zukunft sein aber bis dahin
ich gehe davon aus zehntausende von papers über geier mit geier daten die wissenschaft bereichern.
Na wenn man mal ausschau halten nach neun tiefgehenden erkenntnissen über unser universum und ich sag an dieser stelle erstmal vielen vielen dank für die ausführung über ja ja und den sternen katalog.
Ja was ich vielleicht noch sagen will ist also was ich auch spannend findet das hab ich auch angedeutet ist
ja was man mit zusammenarbeit zwischen verschiedenen gruppen die an einem strang ziehen wirklich für ein tolles projekt auf die beine stellen kann das was ich erzählt habe hab jetzt ich weitgehend erklärt aber das sind so viele leute die da eine ganz tolle arbeit geleistet haben und jeder einzelne da
ist wichtig um so ein projekt ähm am laufen zu.
Teamwork zählt trotzdem gute ausführung vielen dank dafür und vielen dank für's zuhören hier bei uns hat das war 's für heute geht bald wieder weiter.